We are getting ready to plan some travel for the holidays and so we've started to look on Airbnb We love to stay at an Airbnb because when you travel with children and your family It is nice to have a kitchen. It's nice to have you all in one area Jenna, I got a hot tip for you. What is it? Do you know that you could make money off of your home while you're away on vacation? Tell me more. I will. While you're away, your home could be an Airbnb.
我们正准备为假期做一些旅行计划，所以我们开始在Airbnb上寻找住处。我们喜欢住在Airbnb，因为当你带着孩子和家人旅行时，有个厨房会很方便。大家能聚在一个区域也很好。珍娜，我有个绝妙的建议给你。是什么？你知道当你去度假时，你可以利用你的房子赚钱吗？多跟我说说。我会的。当你不在家时，你的房子可以成为Airbnb。
Oh, really? Yeah, think about someone who's frequently traveling. You know? Yeah. While they're away, their home's making them money. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very Shroot Farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't leave. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very shrewt farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't
哦，真的吗？是啊，想想那些经常出差的人。你知道吗？是的。当他们不在家时，他们的房子就能为他们赚钱。那真是太棒了。我知道。这对他们来说非常有“施鲁特农场”的风格。虽然德怀特并没有离开。那真是太棒了。我知道。这对他们来说非常有“施鲁特农场”的风格。虽然德怀特并没有
leave. That's true. And if he did leave, you'd be stuck with Moe's. Yes. Well, it sounds like Airbnb is a really practical way to earn some extra money. If you've stayed at an Airbnb, wouldn't it be cool to give that experience to others? Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.com slash host. When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that actually they will stay for dinner. Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery
离开。那倒是真的。如果他真的离开了，你就只能去莫氏酒馆了。是的。嗯，听起来Airbnb确实是一种赚外快的实用方式。如果你住过Airbnb，把这种体验带给别人不是也很酷吗？你的房子可能比你想象的更有价值。访问airbnb.com/host了解具体价值。什么时候通过Instacart快速送货最重要？当你的招牌芥末土豆沙拉因为少了那份芥末而不再出名时。当烧烤架点着了却没东西可烤时。当姻亲们突然决定他们真的要留下来吃晚饭时。Instacart能满足你这个夏天所有的杂货需求。所以下载应用程序并享受送货服务
in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders, service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello and welcome to your second drink of casino night. This is such a great episode. I mean, John Krasinski was with us. Yes, this was the first time John was on Office Ladies
最快60分钟送达。此外，前三单还可享受0美元配送费，服务费、除外条款和条件适用。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。你好，欢迎来到“赌场之夜”的第二杯饮品。这一集真是太棒了。我是说，约翰·卡拉辛斯基和我们在一起。是的，这是约翰第一次参加《办公室女郎》节目
and it was so fun. We got to reminisce about shooting those scenes in the parking lot and of course the behind the scenes of the Jim Pam kiss. I mean, it wasn't the first Jim and Pam kiss. No, it was not. I conceded that it was not their first kiss. You know, we also revisited Casino Night with director Ken Quapus,
而且非常有趣。我们一起回忆了在停车场拍摄那些场景的往事，当然还有吉姆和帕姆接吻的幕后花絮。我是说，那不是吉姆和帕姆的第一次接吻。不，不是。我承认那不是他们的初吻。你知道，我们还和导演肯·夸皮斯一起重温了“赌场之夜”，
who shared even more fun insights into this episode. And I mean, between these two podcasts, I really couldn't find anything we hadn't covered already. We really fleshed this one out. I did find a few questions in our general mailbag that I thought we could address. Okay. So the first one is for you, Ange,
他分享了更多关于这一集的有趣见解。而且，在这两个播客之间，我真的找不到我们还没涵盖的内容了。我们真的把这一集挖掘得很透彻。我在我们的常规邮件中确实发现了一些我认为我们可以解决的问题。好的。那么第一个问题是给你的，安吉，
and it is from Rachel M. in Genoa, Illinois, who said, I'm watching all the super fan episodes, so it shows the deleted scenes, which I love, but during the deleted scene for Casino Night at one minute and 41 seconds, you see Angela smile about, quote, irritating Cylons for the Mad Libs. Angela, were you breaking character in that moment?
来自伊利诺伊州热那亚的瑞秋·M，她说：“我正在看所有的超级粉丝剧集，所以它展示了被删减的场景，我很喜欢，但在‘赌场之夜’一分四十一秒的被删减场景中，你看到安吉拉因为‘疯狂填词’游戏而笑着说‘烦人的赛昂人’。安吉拉，那一刻你是在跳戏吗？”
Well, Rachel, you know what? Thank you for writing in. I was really curious. I didn't remember that exact moment, so I went back and rewatched it, and I'm actually not breaking. I actually made the choice that Angela's being a little flirty and is delighted to be sitting next to Dwight, and she's very charmed by him. Okay, so this was flirty smile, not breaking smile.
嗯，瑞秋，你知道吗？谢谢你的来信。我真的很好奇。我不记得那个确切的时刻了，所以我回去重看了，其实我并没有跳戏。我当时做出的选择是安吉拉表现得有点调情，并且很高兴能坐在德怀特旁边，她被他深深吸引了。好的，所以那是调情的微笑，而不是跳戏的微笑。
That's right. I mean, listen, anytime Angela smiles, we have to wonder. I know, and I never was given permission really to like laugh or smile, so when I did, I got very excited. All right, next question is from Amelia G in Australia. Amelia says, I have a question for you both. It's more of a, what do you think happened question? So after Pam and Jim's kiss on what we assume was a Friday night,
没错。我是说，听着，任何时候安吉拉微笑，我们都得琢磨一下。我知道，而且我从来没有真正被允许大笑或微笑，所以当我这样做时，我感到非常兴奋。好了，下一个问题来自澳大利亚的阿米莉亚·G。阿米莉亚说：“我有一个问题要问你们俩。这更像是一个‘你们认为发生了什么’的问题。所以在帕姆和吉姆接吻之后，我们假设是在周五晚上，”
how long do you think it was before he moved to Stanford? Jenna, did you have in your PAM file what that Monday morning was like for both of them as we never see or hear about it? Well, Amelia, I did think a lot about this after this episode because I knew that this was our season finale and that there was gonna be a time jump for the next season and Jim was gonna be somewhere else.
“你认为过了多久他才搬到斯坦福？珍娜，你的帕姆档案里有关于那个周一早上对他们俩来说是什么样的记录吗？因为我们从未看到或听到过。”嗯，阿米莉亚，在这一集之后我确实想了很多，因为我知道这是我们的季终集，下一季会有时间跳跃，吉姆会去别的地方。
And I wondered when did he make that move? And I always imagine that he took Jan up on her offer. Well, he has that talking head. He's like, I might as well take her up on it. I mean, I have no future here. Yes. I imagine that he did that like Saturday. Like, he was like, I'm going to take you up on it.
我很好奇他是什么时候做出那个决定的？我一直想象他接受了简的提议。嗯，他有那个独白镜头。他说：“我最好还是接受她的提议。我是说，我在这里没有未来。”是的。我想象他是在周六就做了决定。就像，他说：“我会接受你的提议。”
I don't know if he ever came back to the office. I'm sure he did to get his things. So I'm sure there was, like, an awkward few days. But I think he was out of there pretty quickly. That's my feeling. That tracks for me, too. I think the other question that I really wondered about was, like, when in that timeline did Pam call off the wedding?
我不知道他是否回过办公室。我肯定他回去拿过他的东西。所以我敢肯定，那几天会很尴尬。但我认为他很快就离开了。这是我的感觉。这对我来说也说得通。我想我真正好奇的另一个问题是，在那个时间线上，帕姆是什么时候取消婚礼的？
Was it after Jim left and how long after and yeah. But that was a pretty big summer for both of them. It sure was. Well, our last question is from Fiona L. in Melbourne who said, hi, office ladies. In the commentary for Casino Night, Jenna talks about how when she and John were standing out near the car, and Jim first tells Pam that he's in love with her, Jenna was very excited and distracted
是在吉姆离开之后吗？过了多久？是的。但那对他们俩来说都是一个非常重要的夏天。确实如此。好了，最后一个问题来自墨尔本的菲奥娜·L，她说：“嗨，办公室女郎们。在‘赌场之夜’的评论中，珍娜谈到当她和约翰站在车旁，吉姆第一次告诉帕姆他爱她时，珍娜非常兴奋和分心，”
at what good acting John was doing, and she couldn't wait for him to see it. So I'm wondering, Jenna and Angela, can you tell us about any times on the show when, Jenna, you've been blown away by Angela's performance, or Angela, that you've been blown away by Jenna's performance? What comes to mind? Oh, well, there's so many for you, Jenna.
“因为约翰的演技太好了，她迫不及待地想让他看到。所以我很好奇，珍娜和安吉拉，你们能告诉我们节目中有什么时候，珍娜，你被安吉拉的表演惊艳到了，或者安吉拉，你被珍娜的表演惊艳到了吗？你们想到了什么？”哦，嗯，珍娜，你有很多这样的时刻。
I mean, you have so many great moments as Pam. I always think about that talking head when Jim pops in and asks you out to dinner. And everything that played across Pam's face in such a brief moment, like what you were able to do, the journey you took us on of all these years and hoping for this moment and right there on your face. And it's not even like you had a scene partner really, you had to sort of just have that moment come over you.
我是说，作为帕姆，你有太多精彩的瞬间了。我总是想起那个独白镜头，吉姆突然出现并约你出去吃晚饭。在那么短暂的瞬间，帕姆脸上闪过的所有表情，你所能做到的，你带我们走过的这些年的旅程，对这一刻的期待，就在你的脸上。甚至都不像你有真正的对手戏演员，你只是让那一刻自然流露。
So I always am blown away by that. I mean, for me, it's your moment with Oscar in season nine when you take him up on his offer to stay with him after you've left the senator. I just love that scene, and I love your work in that scene. But I feel like Fiona is wondering if we've ever been in a scene, and while we're in the scene,
所以我总是被那个瞬间惊艳到。我是说，对我来说，是你第九季和奥斯卡在一起的时刻，当你离开参议员后接受了他的提议去和他住在一起。我真的很喜欢那个场景，我也很喜欢你在那个场景中的表演。但我感觉菲奥娜可能是在想，我们是否曾经在同一个场景中，而当我们在场景中时，
were we distracted by each other? By each other. Oh, I see, I see. And the one that popped into my mind was the duel, By each other? By each other. Oh, I see, I see. And the one that popped into my mind was the duel, because I remember you having to sort of like hold all of us in the bullpen with your speech. Right. And I remember watching that and like being distracted by the fact that like you were being like the Steve Carell of that day, you know, and just be like, oh my gosh, I can't wait for my friend to see herself in this moment.
我们是否被彼此分心了？被彼此分心？哦，我明白了，我明白了。我脑海中浮现出的第一个场景是“决斗”，因为我记得你不得不通过演讲来稳住我们所有人。对。我记得看着那个场景，被你那天表现得像史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一样的事实所吸引，你知道，心里想：“天哪，我迫不及待想让我的朋友看到她自己在那一刻的样子。”
Oh, I love that. Honestly, like when we were in the big bullpen and there were the scenes where Pam would take on Ryan in whatever stupid thing he was saying. And I was in the scene with you, so I'm not supposed to be looking at you with like awe, like you go Pam, you get him. But I would have to check myself because I'd be like, oh, that's so good. I'm like totally lost in the moment. But yeah, I loved it when Pam, like when you as Pam like went up against someone, whether it was Michael or Ryan or Dwight, and it was always a big group scene,
哦，我喜欢那个。老实说，当我们在大办公区时，有一些场景是帕姆要对抗瑞安，无论他说什么蠢话。我当时和你在一起，所以我本不应该用那种敬畏的眼神看着你，比如“加油帕姆，干掉他”。但我不得不克制自己，因为我会想：“哦，那太棒了。”我完全沉浸在那个时刻了。但是的，我喜欢帕姆，当你作为帕姆对抗某人时，无论是迈克尔、瑞安还是德怀特，那总是一个大型集体场景，
whether it was the conference room or bullpen, and you just held your own and did your thing. It was always so fun to watch. Aw, well, hey, thanks Fiona for letting us reminisce. That's all I got, folks. I mean, we really covered it. Please enjoy this second drink of Casino Night. And if you want to follow up with Casino Night Revisited
无论是在会议室还是办公区，你都坚持住了自己的立场，做到了你该做的。看着总是那么有趣。噢，好吧，嘿，谢谢菲奥娜让我们回忆往事。我没别的问题了，各位。我是说，我们真的涵盖了所有内容。请享受这第二杯“赌场之夜”。如果你想跟进与导演肯·夸皮斯重温“赌场之夜”的内容，
with director Ken Quapus, we're not going to be playing it in our second drinks, but you can find it on OfficeLadies.com, episode number 36. And here is Casino Night. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
我们不会在第二杯饮品中播放它，但你可以在OfficeLadies.com上找到它，第36集。这就是“赌场之夜”。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Lady luck, roll those dice, it's casino night everyone. Oh luck, roll th night everyone. Oh baby. excited for this episode.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女郎》。幸运女神，掷出骰子，大家，这是赌场之夜。哦，幸运女神，掷出骰子，大家，这是赌场之夜。哦，宝贝。对这一集很兴奋。
this since it aired until episode and Angela, oh my good. It was a saw God re we get started. You guys, you know, we're right now. Yep. And it's if you hear some rain, tha to move into my daughter' rain outside of my closet
自从播出以来，我就一直想看这一集，安吉拉，天哪。这真是上帝的旨意，我们开始吧。伙计们，你们知道，我们现在就在这里。是的。如果你听到一些雨声，那是因为我不得不搬进我女儿的衣柜里，衣柜外面的雨声
like I was tinkling the wanted to sound like inap I know there's rain, but then you know how sometimes the rain happens to come off of a gutter in a sort of waterfalls way. Apparently, that's what happens outside of my closet. So I'm in my my daughter's closet. because all three kids are inside and loud. They're so loud. And I'm just like what? I can't tell them to like not make any noise ever. Yeah. Okay, so here we go. Casino Night.
就像我在叮当作响，想让它听起来像……我知道有雨，但你知道有时雨会以瀑布的方式从排水沟里流下来吗？显然，这就是我衣柜外发生的事情。所以我现在在我女儿的衣柜里。因为三个孩子都在里面，很吵。他们太吵了。我只是想，什么？我不能告诉他们永远不要制造任何噪音。是的。好吧，我们开始吧。赌场之夜。
I'm so excited. Season two, episode 22, written by Steve Carell. Steve Carell. All right, written by Steve Carell, directed by Ken Quapus. This is already off to a good start, Jenna. Oh yeah, this is a good team. All right, hit me with a summary. Here we go.
我太兴奋了。第二季，第22集，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好的，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，肯·夸皮斯导演。珍娜，这已经是一个好的开始了。哦，是的，这是一个很棒的团队。好了，给我一个总结。我们开始吧。
Michael decides to hold a casino night down in the warehouse to benefit charity. However, Michael is going to have to juggle two dates. Mm-hmm. Bum, bum, bum. Also, J his possible transfer to And that's going to lead
迈克尔决定在仓库里举办一场赌场之夜，为慈善事业筹款。然而，迈克尔将不得不周旋于两个约会对象之间。嗯哼。砰，砰，砰。还有，吉姆可能要调职到……那将导致
with Pam. It's a good one some Sam fast facts. Yeah number one written by Steve Carell. So here's something that maybe a lot of people don't know. Steve also co-wrote 40 Year Old Virgin. This is not the first thing that Steve has written. So he got to write this episode. You know, he also wrote another episode of The Office season for episode seven
和帕姆之间。这是一个很好的开始，来点萨姆快讯吧。是的，第一，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。所以这里有一件可能很多人不知道的事情。史蒂夫还共同编剧了《四十岁的老处男》。这不是史蒂夫写的第一部作品。所以他有机会写这一集。你知道，他还写了《办公室》的另一集，第四季第七集
Survivor Man. So we'll get to that one. But I found an old article from the LA Times where Steve did an interview all about how he came to be the writer of this season two finale. Lady, that is some good detective work. I love it. I was very proud of myself. Alright, so here's how it went down. So Steve had the idea as a general episode that Michael should throw a casino night down in the warehouse. And he pitched that idea to Greg and Greg said, Oh, that would make a great setting for the finale episode. And then I guess remember when Steve had to fly to New York to do the Valentine's Day episode on the airplane. Steve and Greg were together and on the way there and on the way back,
《幸存者》。所以我们会讲到那一集。但我从《洛杉矶时报》找到了一篇旧文章，史蒂夫在采访中谈到了他是如何成为第二季季终集编剧的。女士，那真是出色的侦探工作。我喜欢。我当时为自己感到非常自豪。好了，事情是这样的。史蒂夫有一个想法，作为一般剧集，迈克尔应该在仓库里举办一场赌场之夜。他把这个想法告诉了格雷格，格雷格说：“哦，那将是季终集的绝佳背景。”然后我猜记得史蒂夫不得不飞往纽约拍摄情人节那一集的时候，在飞机上。史蒂夫和格雷格在一起，在去程和回程的路上，
they sat down, they sort of plotted out together what the finale would be with this casino night idea. Isn't that incredible? Oh my god, that's amazing! They're on the plane and they're outlining this episode. I love that. And Greg said to Steve, why don't you write it? You should write it. And Steve was like, okay, yeah, I mean, I think that's great.
他们坐下来，一起规划了季终集将如何以这个赌场之夜的想法展开。那不可思议吗？哦，天哪，太棒了！他们在飞机上勾勒这一集。我喜欢这个。格雷格对史蒂夫说：“你为什么不写它？你应该写它。”史蒂夫说：“好的，是的，我是说，我觉得那太棒了。”
But then this is a really fun tidbit. Steve got cold feet. Oh, and he tried to get out of it. Oh, so I guess this was during the time when he was still doing Evan Almighty on the weekends, you know, he would shoot on our show. Sometimes like four days a week, we would shoot him out in four days and then he would fly and on the weekends he would be doing Evan Almighty. And so he flew home and he had one weekend
但这是一个非常有趣的细节。史蒂夫临阵退缩了。哦，他试图退出。哦，我猜这是在他还在周末拍摄《冒牌天神2》的时候，你知道，他会在我们的节目中拍摄。有时一周四天，我们会让他拍摄四天，然后他会飞走，周末他会拍摄《冒牌天神2》。所以他飞回家，他有一个周末
to write this finale script and his parents were in town visiting him at his house. And so he went into Greg's office. And he said, there's, I just don't think I can do it justice. There's no way I can do it. I should get out of it. But Steve had this great quote where he said, I don't know, Greg managed to talk him into doing it anyway. Like Greg has a way where by the time he was leaving Greg's office, he was like, I'm writing this episode again. How did that happen? I should not get out of it. So.
来写这个季终剧本，他的父母当时正在城里拜访他。所以他走进格雷格的办公室。他说：“我只是觉得我无法胜任。我没法做到。我应该退出。”但史蒂夫有一句很棒的话，他说：“我不知道，格雷格还是设法说服了他去做。”就像格雷格有一种方式，当他离开格雷格办公室时，他会说：“我又要写这一集了。这是怎么发生的？我不应该退出。”所以。
That makes me smile because it's very Greg. Greg, you know, we've sort of all said that he was kind of like our dad. Yeah. Although he's not old enough to be our dad, obviously, but he had sort of that father mentor thing of like, you'll figure it out. You're gonna do it.
这让我微笑，因为这非常“格雷格”。格雷格，你知道，我们都说他有点像我们的爸爸。是的。虽然他显然不够老到能当我们的爸爸，但他有一种父亲般的导师感，比如：“你会搞定的。你会做到的。”
It's gonna be okay. And then you're like, wait, what? It's gonna be great. Wait, I can totally see that. I came in here to tell you I'm not doing it. And what? Wait, what? Now I'm writing it.
“一切都会好起来的。”然后你会想：“等等，什么？”“一切都会很棒的。”“等等，我完全能理解。我来这里是想告诉你我不做了。然后什么？等等，什么？现在我在写它。”
Yeah. But he did say he was really pumped. That was the other part of it was that Greg really infused him with this enthusiasm. So he was really excited. So what he did was he went home and he would write the script after his parents went to bed. Aw.
是的。但他确实说他当时真的很兴奋。那是另一部分，格雷格真的给了他这种热情。所以他真的很兴奋。所以他做的是回家，在父母睡觉后写剧本。噢。
So he would stay up at night and write the script and he turned it in. And he said then the writing staff did a bunch of punch ups and like they usually do. And that's how we got the script. Wow, way to go Steve. Way to like- Isn't that crazy? Man, I love that story.
所以他会熬夜写剧本，然后交上去。他说然后编剧团队做了一些润色，就像他们通常做的那样。这就是我们得到剧本的方式。哇，干得好，史蒂夫。干得好……那不疯狂吗？伙计，我喜欢那个故事。
All right, that was a good one. Moving on to fast fact number two. This is a supersized episode. Greg said that he was doing an interview for the Chicago Tribune, and he had mentioned in the interview kind of casually that he wished that the finale for season two could be supersized.
好了，那是一个很好的故事。继续快讯第二条。这是一集超长剧集。格雷格说他在接受《芝加哥论坛报》采访时，随口提到他希望第二季的季终集能超长。
Well, this started a whole online petition by office fans. They started writing in like crazy to NBC, give me my remote, Northern Attack and office tally started these online petitions. And it was the fans that got us the supersized episode. That's great. And you know what, this was before Twitter and Instagram, it was not easy to start an online petition back then. Yeah, no, you didn't have the same outreach. And they really just like kept at it. And NBC was like, okay.
嗯，这引发了办公室粉丝的整个在线请愿。他们开始疯狂地写信给NBC，“把我的遥控器给我”，Northern Attack和Office Tally发起了这些在线请愿。正是粉丝们让我们得到了超长剧集。那太棒了。而且你知道吗，这还是在推特和Instagram之前，那时候发起在线请愿并不容易。是的，没有同样的传播渠道。他们真的坚持了下来。NBC说：“好吧。”
And Greg was thrilled. Thank you so much to the Office fans for making that happen because I could not imagine this episode being 22 minutes. There's so much we would have missed. I wish this episode was an hour. I could have watched even more. I know, but I kind of feel like that
格雷格非常激动。非常感谢《办公室》的粉丝们让这一切发生，因为我无法想象这一集只有22分钟。我们错过了太多东西。我希望这一集是一个小时。我可以看更多。我知道，但我感觉
about almost all the episodes. But this one in particular, I'm so happy with Longer. That's what she said. That's what she said. Well, speaking of Longer, this podcast is probably also gonna be supersized today because, well, we're gonna have a special guest join us later.
几乎所有剧集都是这样。但这一集特别让我高兴，更长了。这就是她说的。这就是她说的。说到更长，这个播客今天可能也会超长，因为，嗯，我们稍后会有特别嘉宾加入。
Jenna and I got to talk to someone about this episode and this person was such a delight. Jenna, we talked for like almost an hour. We did. And we just want y all. So buckle in, it's g episode. It is, it's gonna Bum bum bum, wink, wink,
珍娜和我得以和某人谈论这一集，这个人真是太令人愉快了。珍娜，我们谈了快一个小时。我们确实谈了。我们只是想让你们……所以系好安全带，这一集会很棒。它会的，它会……砰砰砰，眨眼，眨眼，
three, we got a lot of qu about what it was like to into a casino. I mean, se we talk about this for a we talk about Dunder Mifl transform the warehouse i mean, seriously, can we t second? Can we talk about budget for parties? I mea planning committee, I usua and a cake that I mean an
三，我们有很多关于进入赌场是什么感觉的问题。我是说，我们谈论这个……我们谈论邓德·米夫林把仓库改造成赌场，我是说，真的，我们可以谈谈派对预算吗？我是说，策划委员会，我通常……还有蛋糕，我是说……
cloth. It's true. But then a booze cruise. He throws night. Where is he getting the money for this? At eight seconds, Jenna, you see them converting the warehouse and there's all these extra employees. There's giant neon signs. There's dealers.
桌布。这是真的。但后来还有游船派对。他举办了赌场之夜。他从哪里弄来的钱？在八秒处，珍娜，你看到他们改造仓库，还有所有这些额外的员工。有巨大的霓虹灯。有荷官。
I mean, where is this budget coming from? That I don't know. That I don't know. But I did reach out to Kentopedia to find out how we transformed the warehouse into a casino and this is what he said. He said that he hired a company that specialized in creating casinos for special events
我是说，这个预算是从哪里来的？我不知道。我不知道。但我确实联系了肯托佩迪亚，想了解我们是如何把仓库改造成赌场的，他是这么说的。他说他雇了一家专门为特殊活动创建赌场的公司，
like Christmas parties or college fundraisers. I've been to those things. I've been to fundraisers that are casino nights. And so there are these companies and they send dealers, they send all the equipment. And so he just said he hired one of those companies and then he used all the employees from the company as extras in the episode. What was this budget? I'm sorry, I can't stop talking about the budget, but it was it was crazy. Do you think we raised more money than the party cost? No.
比如圣诞派对或大学筹款活动。我去过那些地方。我去过赌场之夜的筹款活动。所以有这些公司，他们派荷官，他们派所有设备。所以他只是说他雇了其中一家公司，然后他用了公司所有的员工作为剧中的临时演员。这个预算是多少？抱歉，我不能停止谈论预算，但这太疯狂了。你认为我们筹到的钱比派对成本多吗？不。
No. It was definitely a loss. It was a loss, for sure. Speaking of the whole casino setup, fan question from ExplorinLauren, she asked, in between scenes, did you all play any poker games? Did you, Amj? Did you play any of the games?
不。这绝对是亏损的。这绝对是亏损。说到整个赌场设置，来自ExplorinLauren的粉丝问题，她问：“在场景之间，你们都玩扑克游戏吗？你玩了吗，安吉？你玩了任何游戏吗？”
No, I didn't. Did you? Oh, yeah. You did? Oh, yeah. There were any time that I was sitting. You love poker. I know. And it was professional dealers. So my character was stationed at the poker tables too. So whenever I was in the background of any scenes, I was sitting at a poker table and we played poker. It was like the greatest time. I mean I have a memory of like sitting and watching you guys play cards because I really didn't know how to play poker. I only just
不，我没有。你玩了吗？哦，是的。你玩了？哦，是的。任何时候我坐着的时候。你喜欢扑克。我知道。而且有专业的荷官。所以我的角色也被安排在扑克桌旁。所以每当我在任何场景的背景中时，我都会坐在扑克桌旁，我们玩扑克。那是最好的时光。我是说，我记得坐着看你们玩牌，因为我真的不知道怎么玩扑克。我只是刚
learned I'm not great. I mean I always think I can win with a pair of threes. I'm that I'm basically Phyllis. You can I know but I'm basically you know Phyllis, look, the one with the flower one, yeah, the clovers. But a lot of you guys were poker players. I mean, Rain had a poker tournament, didn't he? In his garage or something. You guys all went. Yeah, it was the people who played the most together outside of work were me, Rain, David Denman, Chris Workman and Ed Nielsen Jr. Those guys were on the crew. And I'm trying to think who else, but there was a little group of us, like six or eight of us,
学会，我不太擅长。我是说，我总是认为我可以用一对三赢。我基本上就是菲利斯。你可以……我知道，但我基本上是，你知道菲利斯，看，那个有花的，是的，梅花。但你们很多人都是扑克玩家。我是说，雷恩举办过扑克锦标赛，不是吗？在他的车库里什么的。你们都去了。是的，在工作之外玩得最多的人是我、雷恩、大卫·丹曼、克里斯·沃克曼和埃德·尼尔森二世。那些人是剧组人员。我在想还有谁，但我们有一小群人，大概六八个人，
and we would go to Rain's garage and play poker on the weekends. Yeah, so I love that you guys were doing that in between scenes. I'm sure I just was sitting there being chatty. Well, listen, I think we should take a break and get into this episode because like we said, it is a long one.
我们周末会去雷恩的车库玩扑克。是的，所以我喜欢你们在场景之间做那个。我肯定我只是坐在那里聊天。好吧，听着，我想我们应该休息一下，进入这一集，因为正如我们所说，这是一集很长的剧集。
So we'll be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well you know mental health awareness is growing now but there's still progress to be made. 26 percent of Americans who
所以我们马上回来。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。我刚去看了我妈妈，我一直在想她作为成年人真正影响我生活的方方面面。我非常钦佩她的一点是，当她需要帮助时，她总是愿意寻求帮助。为自己辩护。是的。嗯，你知道心理健康意识现在正在增长，但仍有进展要做。26%的美国人
participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking mental health support due to fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. Better Help is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today
在最近的一项调查中表示，由于害怕被评判，他们避免寻求心理健康支持。在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人照顾好自己的幸福，打破污名。Better Help完全在线。它使治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。你可以随时免费更换治疗师。我们有了帮助会更好。今天访问betterhelp.com/office ladies
to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. I'm Emma Greede and I've spent the last 20 years building, running and investing in some incredible businesses. The more success I've had, the more people started coming to me with questions. How do you start a business? How do you raise money? How do I bounce back from failure? On my new podcast, Aspire with Emma Greed, I'll be answering these questions and more through weekly conversations with the smartest minds out there. Listen to and follow Aspire with Emma Greed, an Odyssey podcast available now,
即可获得首月10%的折扣。那是betterhelp, H-E-L-P点com斜杠office ladies。我是艾玛·格里德，过去20年我一直在建立、经营和投资一些令人难以置信的企业。我取得的成功越多，来问我问题的人就越多。你如何创业？你如何筹集资金？我如何从失败中反弹？在我的新播客《Aspire with Emma Greed》中，我将通过与最聪明的人进行每周对话来回答这些问题及更多内容。收听并关注《Aspire with Emma Greed》，这是一个Odyssey播客，现已上线，
wherever you get your podcasts. There are very few things that you can be certain of in life. But you can always be sure the sun will rise each morning. You can bet your bottom dollar that you'll always need air to breathe and water to drink. And of course, you can rest assured that with Public Mobile's 5G subscription phone plans, you'll pay the same thing every month. With all of the mysteries that life has to offer, a few certainties can really go a long way.
无论你在哪里获取播客。生活中你可以确定的事情很少。但你可以肯定太阳每天早上都会升起。你可以确信你总是需要空气来呼吸，水来喝。当然，你可以放心，使用Public Mobile的5G订阅电话套餐，你每个月支付的费用都是一样的。生活中充满了奥秘，一些确定性真的大有裨益。
Subscribe today for the peace of mind you've been searching for. Public Mobile. Different is calling. Okay, we are back. And let's get into this episode, Jenna. We've got a lot of ground to cover and at 36 seconds Dwight's in a tuxedo. Game on. It's starting. Oh yeah, he explains that it's a family heirloom. His grandfather was buried in it. Yeah, so that's special. And now you have a Jim Pam prank. right? Can we talk for one quick second
今天订阅，获得你一直在寻找的安心。Public Mobile。与众不同在召唤。好的，我们回来了。让我们进入这一集，珍娜。我们有很多内容要讲，在36秒处，德怀特穿着燕尾服。比赛开始。开始了。哦，是的，他解释说这是传家宝。他祖父穿着它下葬。是的，所以这很特别。现在你有一个吉姆和帕姆的恶作剧，对吧？我们可以谈谈一秒钟吗
about the fact that Pam winks at Jim with Roy right there? I have that down, I have that down. So yes, Roy and Pam, they're talking about casino night. This starts a whole conversation about who can win roulette. Right? Jim says he can win by using mind control. And Dwight says, oh really? You can do mind control.
关于帕姆在罗伊就在旁边时向吉姆眨眼的事实？我记下来了，我记下来了。所以是的，罗伊和帕姆，他们在谈论赌场之夜。这引发了关于谁能在轮盘赌中获胜的整个对话。对。吉姆说他可以通过使用意念控制获胜。德怀特说：“哦，真的吗？你会意念控制。”
Why don't you try moving the coat rack? So he stares at it and it moves to everyone's surprise. And then Pam winks at Jim. And I wrote down, discuss, how do we feel about this? It's a big wink. It's not like, and Roy is right there. Is he, yeah, does he not have eyes? Is he not looking at his fiance?
“你为什么不试着移动那个衣帽架？”所以他盯着它看，在大家的惊讶中它移动了。然后帕姆向吉姆眨眼。我写下来了，讨论一下，我们对这个感觉如何？这是一个很大的眨眼。不像……而且罗伊就在旁边。他……是的，他没有眼睛吗？他没有看着他的未婚妻吗？
What the hell, why are you winking at Jim? So the flirt is starting early on. This is early. For sure. Early in the evening. It's not even the evening, it's the day. The flirt is starting early on. This is early. For sure early in the evening. It's not even the evening. It's the day. Well, I starting I had a fan question from batya who said was the wink Pam gave Jim scripted? Yes, it was I was gonna say absolutely. It was it was in the script. I actually I
搞什么鬼，你为什么要向吉姆眨眼？所以调情很早就开始了。这很早。当然。在傍晚，甚至不是傍晚，是白天。调情很早就开始了。这很早。当然，在傍晚。甚至不是傍晚，是白天。嗯，我开始……我有一个来自Batya的粉丝问题，她说：“帕姆给吉姆的那个眨眼是剧本写的吗？”是的，它是。我本来想说绝对是。它在剧本里。我其实
have the script from this episode Angela. I love that you have the script. What did what so you What go to it? Yeah, I looked there. It says Pam winks another fan question to f the cold open Jenna, did coat rack with an umbrella Jenna what in a time caps capsule called the DVD commentary you talk about it. Oh I went into it? Yeah you went into it. You said that there was a crew member that had a string.
有这一集的剧本，安吉拉。我喜欢你有剧本。你……去看看？是的，我看了。上面写着“帕姆眨眼”。另一个粉丝问题关于冷开场，珍娜，那个带雨伞的衣帽架，珍娜，在DVD评论中你谈到了它。哦，我谈到了？是的，你谈到了。你说有一个剧组成员有一根绳子。
It was like a clear like fishing line. We tried to have me do it. We tried to have me use the little even like tried to have me use that string thing and you just saw my arm moving too much. I was too far away. Like the umbrella with the hook on the end, I couldn't even reach the coat rack with it. I was going to say the coat rack is actually further away from you than people realize. Yeah. It's actually quite far from you. But the optical illusion makes it kind of seem like I could have, but no, I wasn't really doing it. And then Pam is very proud of herself because she has a silent
那就像一根透明的钓鱼线。我们试着让我做。我们试着让我用那个小的，甚至试着让我用那个绳子，你只是看到我的手臂移动得太多了。我离得太远了。就像那个末端有钩子的雨伞，我甚至用它够不到衣帽架。我本来想说衣帽架其实比人们意识到的离你更远。是的。它其实离你很远。但视觉错觉让它看起来好像我可以做到，但没有，我并没有真的在做。然后帕姆为自己感到非常自豪，因为她有一个无声的
talking head where she's showing off the umbrella. And Jenna, you're like as Pam, you are beaming. You're so proud of that moment. I know. Well, I think it's meant, you know, that wasn't set up that whole idea of mind control. I think the idea of that was that in the moment, Pam figured out how to have Jim's back. Yeah. And so I think she's like, that's where the wink comes from. And that's why she's so proud. Exactly. She's super proud. They didn't know Dwight was going to pick the coat rack. Pam didn't know that Jim was going to set that up. No. Yeah, she's like, Look what I did. Oh my god.
独白镜头，她在炫耀那把雨伞。珍娜，你作为帕姆，你在发光。你为那一刻感到非常自豪。我知道。嗯，我想它的意思是，你知道，那不是预先设定的，那个意念控制的想法。我想那个想法是，在那一刻，帕姆想出了如何支持吉姆。是的。所以我认为这就是眨眼的来源。这就是她为什么那么自豪。没错。她超级自豪。他们不知道德怀特会选衣帽架。帕姆不知道吉姆会那样安排。不。是的，她就像：“看我做了什么。”天哪。
I know. I had another fan question, Angela. This is from Chelsea Glover. Were there any deleted scenes that you're sad didn't make the final cut? And actually, there is an original cold open to this episode. This little prank bit with the coat wrap, this was actually originally meant to go after the credit sequence. And there's a whole cold open that was cut out, but that you can see on the DVD extras.
我知道。我还有另一个粉丝问题，安吉拉。这是来自切尔西·格洛弗的。有什么被删减的场景让你遗憾没有进入最终剪辑吗？其实，这一集有一个原始的冷开场。这个关于衣帽架的小恶作剧，其实最初是打算放在片头字幕之后的。有一个完整的冷开场被剪掉了，但你可以在DVD花絮中看到。
Did you watch it, Angela? It's where Michael brings us into the conference room and makes us do a Dunder Mifflin themed mad lib. Mad libs, yes, it's great. Yeah. So I, I kind of cool, but we didn' had to cut it out. Well, l big thing to point out. I of you guys were thinking
你看了吗，安吉拉？那是迈克尔把我们带进会议室，让我们做一个邓德·米夫林主题的疯狂填词。疯狂填词，是的，太棒了。是的，所以我……有点酷，但我们不得不剪掉它。好吧，一个要指出的重要事情。我……你们中的一些人当时在想
to be talking about it. I stop for a moment. What i one second, there's a new plant at reception. A new potted plant. There is a yellow flowering plant at reception. This is a big deal, guys. We got so much mail about this.
要谈论它。我停顿了一会儿。什么……一秒钟，接待处有一株新植物。一盆新盆栽。接待处有一株黄色的开花植物。这可是件大事，伙计们。我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。
We got no mail about it. But I always crack up whenever Pam. I feel like it's Pam brings in a plant and then it doesn't live very long, but she tries. That's my backstory. She tries to it's like casino night. I'll buy a plant at the, you know, at the pharmacy. They have those plants by the checkout.
我们没收到关于它的邮件。但我每次看到帕姆都会笑。我觉得是帕姆带进来一株植物，然后它活不了多久，但她尝试了。这是我的背景故事。她尝试……就像赌场之夜。我会去药店买一株植物，你知道，结账处有那些植物。
I'll buy one. She's doing her best. She's trying to cheer to the reception de the scene where Michael i Jan. Uh, she's trying to about what's going on wit he just invites her to ca
我会买一株。她尽力了。她试图……接待处……迈克尔和简的场景。呃，她试图……关于正在发生的事情……他只是邀请她去赌场……
she's like Michael, she's and he wants to have this elaborate party that costs so much money. Yeah And she's just like Michael. I'm not I'm not coming to that but mmm Maybe later Something else. Okay. So next up at four minutes 11 seconds Michael's in the bullpen. He's sitting on Pam's desk Mm-hmm. Pam's explaining that we're hav the beneficiary is Boy Sc the big winner of the ni
她说：“迈克尔，她……”他想举办这个花费这么多钱的精心派对。是的。她只是说：“迈克尔，我不会去那里的，但嗯……也许晚点……”其他事情。好的。接下来在四分十一秒，迈克尔在办公区。他坐在帕姆的桌子上。嗯哼。帕姆解释说我们正在……受益人是童子军……当晚的大赢家……
$500 to donate to the cha and a mini fridge comple Yes, to which Phyllis is proud. If you freeze at f Phyllis is so proud. Oh my gosh. So proud. If you freeze at four minutes, 34 seconds, Phyllis's face, she actually sticks her tongue out. It's like, what? She's so happy that Vance Refrigeration is donating the prize. But before we get there, I have to point out a great screen grab at four minutes, 14 seconds.
500美元捐给慈善机构，还有一个迷你冰箱，完整版。是的，菲利斯对此感到自豪。如果你在四分三十四秒定格，菲利斯的脸，她实际上伸出了舌头。这就像，什么？她很高兴万斯制冷公司捐赠了奖品。但在我们到达那里之前，我必须指出四分十四秒的一个很棒的截图。
For those of you guys that have been tuning in. I talk about what I call the accountant stack. It's how they stack the accounting department to get them in the bullpen right because we're tucked around the corner. Yeah so you wouldn't see us so they would pull us out in this formation and it's the best screen grab of it I have seen yet. It is me at the copier with Oscar just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet seen yet. It is me at the copier with Oscar just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet behind Oscar. It is like literally we look like a row of dominoes and it's so we could be in the scene and react.
对于那些一直在收听的你们。我谈论我所谓的“会计堆叠”。这就是他们堆叠会计部门以让他们进入办公区的方式，因为我们被塞在角落里。是的，所以你不会看到我们，所以他们会把我们拉出来形成这个阵型，这是我见过的最好的截图。是我在复印机旁，奥斯卡就在我身后两英尺，然后布莱恩就在奥斯卡身后三英尺。这就像字面上我们看起来像一排多米诺骨牌，这样我们就可以在场景中并做出反应。
That is perfect. I remember that they would do that and sometimes it would make no sense that everyone else was able to sit at their desks and listen to Michael, but you guys would have to get up and walk over a little bit and stand. And during those seats you have to stand the whole time. Yes, I would be so envious of people that got to sit through really long scenes because we'd just be standing by the copier. Oh, that's a good thing when you're re-watching these episodes for people to just know how often the accountants are standing up. Yeah, while everyone else is sitting. So then we lead into this series of talking heads where
那太完美了。我记得他们会那样做，有时其他人能坐在桌子旁听迈克尔说话，而你们却不得不站起来走过去一点站着，这毫无意义。在那些场景中，你必须一直站着。是的，我会非常羡慕那些能坐着拍很长场景的人，因为我们只能站在复印机旁。哦，当人们重温这些剧集时，知道会计们站着有多频繁是一件好事。是的，而其他人都在坐着。然后我们进入这一系列独白镜头，
everyone explains where they would donate the money should they be the big winner for the night. And you know Creed has a talking head where he says he's going to give the money to a soup kitchen He's going to give the money to a soup kitchen. Yeah. That has a really delicious pea soup on Thursdays. Oh, creed. Creed. Kevin says to animals or people, once again reminding us, is maybe not the smartest person. Angela, you have a great talking head.
每个人都解释如果他们是当晚的大赢家，他们会把钱捐给哪里。你知道克里德有一个独白镜头，他说他要把钱捐给一家救济食堂。他要把钱捐给一家救济食堂。是的。周四有非常美味的豌豆汤。哦，克里德。克里德。凯文说给动物或人，再次提醒我们，可能不是最聪明的人。安吉拉，你有一个很棒的独白镜头。
So much sass. I am not wanting to participate in this casino night. I say that we're j money that's from gamblin drugs or prostitute ourse that money to charity. I she's a not happy because plan this party. B is gam
太多的傲慢了。我不想参加这个赌场之夜。我说我们是……钱是来自赌博、毒品或妓女……把那笔钱捐给慈善机构。我……她不高兴，因为……策划这个派对。B是赌博……
alcohol, but Jenna, she s gonna show up later to Yeah, she does. So this l favorite scenes with some of all time ever from the what you're saying. I know talk about. Michael annou the night, they're going
酒精，但珍娜，她……稍后会出现……是的，她确实出现了。所以这是……最喜欢的场景，是有史以来最棒的……你所说的。我知道谈论。迈克尔宣布……当晚，他们要……
check to some boy scouts. He's so him, right? He's so de can have a giant check an Oh, actually, Michael, th then he lists the many re be inappropriate to have casino night. He's like g It's in a dangerous wareh night, Hooters is catering, do I
支票给一些童子军。他太……他了，对吧？他太……可以有一张巨大的支票和……哦，其实，迈克尔，那……然后他列举了许多……举办赌场之夜是不合适的。他说……它在一个危险的仓库里……之夜，猫头鹰餐厅在提供餐饮，我还需要多说吗？
need to say more? Yeah, do I need to go on? So this leads to the classic Michael line. Why are you the way that you are? Michael Sass, I wrote Michael Sass. Michael Sass. This next line is my most absolute favorite, Angela. Mm-hmm. I hate so much about the things that you choose to be.
是的，我需要继续吗？所以这引出了经典的迈克尔台词。你为什么是现在的你？迈克尔的傲慢，我写了“迈克尔的傲慢”。迈克尔的傲慢。下一句是我绝对最喜欢的，安吉拉。嗯哼。我非常讨厌你选择成为的样子。
I could not get through that. So that whole thing that Michael says like that, why are you the way that you are? All of that was scripted. It's in the script word for word. So good. Then Michael announces that he is going to donate to Afghanistan is with AIDS. Well, we got a fan question from Augusta.
我无法完成那个。所以迈克尔说的所有那些话，比如“你为什么是现在的你？”所有这些都是剧本写的。剧本里逐字逐句都有。太棒了。然后迈克尔宣布他要捐给阿富汗人，还有艾滋病。嗯，我们收到了一个来自奥古斯塔的粉丝问题。
She said one of my absolute favorite scenes of all time is the Afghan Afghanistan scene. Was any of that improvised or was that all scripted? All right, I went to the script and mostly all scripted, with the exception of one line, which is John Krasinski. He improvised Afghanistanis. He was supposed to just say Afghanistan's. Way to go, John.
她说：“我绝对最喜欢的场景之一是阿富汗场景。那是即兴创作的还是剧本写的？”好了，我看了剧本，大部分都是剧本写的，除了有一句台词，那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基的。他即兴创作了“阿富汗人”。他本应该只说“阿富汗”。干得好，约翰。
Well, is it a good way to put a way to go. Way to put to you about what happens seconds. Oh yeah. Because happy. Oh my gosh. So hap Roy was gonna to pick the band, but now he's too busy planning his bachelor party. I mean, how many red flags does someone need? She's planning her wedding with the guy she's in love with that's not her fiance. Yeah. And then Jim has the line that breaks your heart at eight minutes he says I mean I talked to Jan about a transfer because I have no future here yeah he has no future there I know I know so now they go you know we're jumping around a little but let's let's see this Jim Pam moment through
嗯，这是一个好方法……关于几秒钟后发生的事情。哦，是的。因为……快乐。哦，天哪。太快乐了。罗伊本来要选乐队，但现在他太忙于策划他的单身派对。我是说，一个人需要多少个危险信号？她正在和她爱的人策划婚礼，那不是她的未婚夫。是的。然后吉姆在八分钟处说了那句让你心碎的台词，他说：“我是说，我和简谈过调职，因为我在这里没有未来。”是的，他在那里没有未来。我知道，我知道。所以现在他们去……你知道，我们跳来跳去，但让我们看看这个吉姆和帕姆的时刻。
okay lady all right they're in the conference room they're watching these band videos. By the way we got a ton of questions about Brian's drumming. So many people wrote in. Yes so they put in a tape and they realized oh my gosh that's Kevin. Yeah. Kevin is in a band. Guess who came up with the band name Scrantonicity? Who? Mindy. Really? That was Mindy. That was Mindy. That's, that was her idea. That name. Well, check this out. When I looked at this scene in the script, the name of the band is not Scrantonicity.
好的，女士，好的，他们在会议室里，他们在看这些乐队视频。顺便说一下，我们收到了大量关于布莱恩打鼓的问题。很多人写信来问。是的，他们放了一盘磁带，然后意识到，天哪，那是凯文。是的。凯文在一个乐队里。猜猜是谁想出了“Scrantonicity”这个乐队名字？谁？明迪。真的吗？那是明迪。那是明迪。那是她的主意。那个名字。好吧，看看这个。当我在剧本里看到这一幕时，乐队的名字并不是Scrantonicity。
Oh yeah, what was it? Jokers and Tokers. So I texted Brian because we got a lot of questions about, is he really drumming? Is hem singing? Yeah. And I also of this jokers and tokers told me that he is actua a Steve Miller song in th he says he's playing, but
哦，是的，那是什么？Jokers and Tokers。所以我给布莱恩发了短信，因为我们收到了很多问题，问他是不是真的在打鼓？他在唱歌吗？是的。而且我还问了关于Jokers and Tokers的事，他告诉我他实际上是在唱一首史蒂夫·米勒的歌，他说他在演奏，但是
faking it because he did to drum until later when his band had t it Phyllis's wedding? Ye stage, right? Yeah. So he his way through the song. this whole scene of him a could not get permission use the song. So in post
他在假装，因为他直到后来他的乐队在菲利斯的婚礼上表演时才真正打鼓？是的，在舞台上，对吧？是的。所以他在那首歌里装模作样。他整个这一幕都无法获得使用这首歌的许可。所以在后期制作中
a police tribute band and the's when they changed the name to Scrantonicity and Brian had to dub his voice singing Don't Stand So Close to Me. And that's what they ended up playing. So if you watch that video, the lyrics do not match his mouth. I didn't notice it until after Brian told me all this stuff though. Oh, that's good. I noticed it until after all this stuff though. Oh based on this knowledge. hand putting the tape int
一个警察致敬乐队，那就是他们把名字改成Scrantonicity的时候，布莱恩不得不为他唱《Don't Stand So Close to Me》配音。这就是他们最终演奏的曲子。所以如果你看那个视频，歌词和他的嘴型对不上。不过在布莱恩告诉我这一切之前，我并没有注意到。哦，那很好。在这一切之后我才注意到。哦，基于这些知识。手把磁带放进
later. I remember having to do a pickup of John's hand putting in Scrantonicity. Okay. And then later in the warehouse, you know, Roy is gonna come up to Kevin and he's gonna say, hey, I heard about your band Scrantonicity, right? This happens at 22 minutes and 5 seconds. Yeah. The band name is said off-camera. It's Roy's voice, but on-camera is Kevin and they had to dub that too. That was some good behind the scenes tidbits for Scrantonicity lady. I know. Thank you, Brian Baumgartner. Okay, so we're jumping around a bit but back at 8 minutes 16 seconds.
后来。我记得不得不补拍约翰把Scrantonicity磁带放进去的手部特写。好的。然后后来在仓库里，你知道，罗伊会走到凯文面前说，嘿，我听说你的乐队Scrantonicity了，对吧？这发生在22分5秒。是的。乐队名字是在镜头外说的。那是罗伊的声音，但镜头里是凯文，他们也不得不给那段配音。对于Scrantonicity女士来说，这真是一些很棒的幕后花絮。我知道。谢谢你，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。好的，我们跳跃得有点多，但回到8分16秒。
We have Darryl in Michael's office. He's like look, I'm not having fire eaters in a paper warehouse. So why does he want fire eaters at a casino night anyway? Let me tell you, he would have a full circus in there if he could. He wants it bigger, louder, crazier. And then Dwight enters for quote protection. And then there's this very funny exchange where we learn that Darryl has taught phrases to Michael to help him with his interracial conversations.
达里尔在迈克尔的办公室里。他说，听着，我可不想在纸张仓库里弄什么吞火表演者。那么他为什么要在赌场之夜请吞火表演者呢？让我告诉你，如果可以的话，他会在那里办一个完整的马戏团。他想要更大、更吵、更疯狂。然后德怀特为了所谓的“保护”进来了。然后有一段非常有趣的对话，我们了解到达里尔教了迈克尔一些短语，以帮助他进行跨种族对话。
We learn about dink and flicka. Dink and flicka. This handshake. And Daryl has a great talking head. And Jenna, I'm pretty sure that this is Craig Robinson's very first talking head, I think in this episode. I think it is.
我们了解到了“dink and flicka”。Dink and flicka。这个握手。达里尔有一个很棒的采访镜头。珍娜，我很确定这是克雷格·罗宾逊的第一个采访镜头，我想是在这一集里。我想是的。
Well, Angela, I looked up dink and flicka on Urban Dictionary. You did? Oh yeah. Does it reference the office? Yes. It says made popular in a recent episode of The Office, Dink and Flicka roughly translates to That's Life or C'est la vie. I sort of remember that as talking about that Dink and Flicka and that Steve had just made it up. I don't know if I'm remembering that wrong. But I think that is just out of Steve
嗯，安吉拉，我在城市词典上查了“dink and flicka”。你查了？哦，是的。它提到《办公室》了吗？是的。它说在《办公室》最近的一集中流行起来，“Dink and Flicka”大致翻译为“这就是生活”或“C'est la vie”。我隐约记得讨论过Dink and Flicka，而且是史蒂夫编出来的。我不知道我记错了没有。但我认为那完全是出自史蒂夫
Correll's mind. Also Fleece it out. But I thin of Steve Correll's mind. out. That was another on the urban dictionary. I k these two made up phrases urban dictionary as sort Way to go. Steve Correll Well, there is some delici up. Oh yes. Okay. All rig so much. I this is one of way to go Steve Correll. delicious Pam sass coming
卡瑞尔的脑子。还有“Fleece it out”。但我认为那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的脑子。那是城市词典上的另一个。我知道这两个编造的短语在城市词典上算是……干得好，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好吧，有一些美味的……哦，是的。好的。好的，非常感谢。我觉得这是……干得好，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。美味的帕姆的傲慢即将到来
All right. I love this bi is one of the things our love work. We find out in something a character has but we didn't know it and those moments. So at 10 m still calls and Pam's's on the phone and where she doesn't let it
好的。我喜欢这个……这是我们喜欢的工作内容之一。我们在某处发现了一个角色有某种特质，但我们之前不知道，就是那些时刻。所以在10分钟……还在打电话，帕姆在电话上，她没有让它……
like still me, still me. to. She says Michael is b attempt. He's better at h people because the first ridiculous thing. What di down? What does he say to He says, Hey Carol, how's Is it real good? Pam's li
就像“还是我，还是我”。她说是迈克尔在尝试。他更擅长和人打交道，因为第一次太荒谬了。他说了什么？他怎么对她说？他说，嘿，卡罗尔，你好吗？真的很好吗？帕姆就像……
and then the second time normal. Yeah, he's like, up. It's so good. And the This is a great scene. So with Carol and she just n for his mortgage insuranc happens. This is a great Michael's on the phone wi just needs one last signat insurance. That's why she tells Carol you should co
然后第二次正常了。是的，他就像，起来。太好了。这个……这是一个很棒的场景。所以和卡罗尔在一起，她只是……为了他的抵押贷款保险……发生了。这是一个很棒的……迈克尔在和卡罗尔通电话，他只需要最后一个签名……保险。这就是为什么她告诉卡罗尔你应该来……
and she's like, um, yeah the signature or she's, i little confusing what he' Nancy did such a great jo been like, wait to your p your party. That's where I get the signature. Yes, we should remind people guys, Carol stills played by Nancy Correll, Steve's wife in real life. So then the other line, Pam's putting through another call. It's Jan. And Jan is calling to tell Michael, Michael, I would love to come to Casino Night.
然后她就像，嗯，是的，签名，或者她，有点困惑他到底……南希做得太棒了，就像，等一下，去你的派对。那就是我得到签名的地方。是的，我们应该提醒大家，卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯是由南希·卡瑞尔扮演的，史蒂夫现实生活中的妻子。所以另一条线上，帕姆正在转接另一个电话。是简。简打电话来告诉迈克尔，迈克尔，我很乐意来参加赌场之夜。
I feel like you can watch Steve as Michael, like literally break into a sweat. He's like, holy crap. When in a million years did I think that I'd have two women on the line who both just said yes to me within seconds of each other. Two queens on casino night. Gonna have to drop a deuce. Oh boy. So that's that's a big cliffhanger. We go into like what would normally be a commercial break right there. Should we go into a break? Let's go into a break because now we're gonna get into the casino game and a lot, a lot is going to happen. All right, we are back and we are at the casino.
我觉得你可以看着史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔，简直要冒汗了。他就像，天哪。我什么时候想过我会在同一时间有两位女士在电话线上，她们都刚刚答应了我。赌场之夜的两位女王。得去拉个屎了。哦，天哪。所以这是一个巨大的悬念。我们进入了通常是商业广告的时间。我们要休息一下吗？让我们休息一下，因为现在我们要进入赌场游戏了，会有很多很多事情发生。好的，我们回来了，我们在赌场。
The casino is open. Gambling is happening. It's open for business. At 13 minutes, 22 seconds, it is happening, Jenna. You are wearing quite the dress. Oh, everyone got very dressed up for this. We got a You are wearing quite the dress. Oh, everyone got very dressed up for this. We got a ton of mail about your dress. Matt Mabe said, how many different dresses did you try on before you settled on the blue one that you wore?
赌场开了。赌博正在进行。它开始营业了。在13分22秒，正在进行中，珍娜。你穿的这件裙子真不错。哦，每个人都为这个盛装打扮。我们收到了……你穿的这件裙子真不错。哦，每个人都为这个盛装打扮。我们收到了大量关于你裙子的邮件。马特·梅布说，在你决定穿那件蓝色的之前，你试穿了多少件不同的裙子？
Danny Thurigood said, my wife has a theory that the dress Pam wears was an old bridesmaids dress that Pam had in her closet. Danny, I wrote on a note card, Pam in a bridesmaids dress? Question mark. It really looks like a bridesmaids dress. It really does. Yes. And then original Gus Girl said, whose decision was it for Pam to wear her watch with her gown? It was a subtle, but great costuming and character choice. I love all of these questions. You guys are so observant. All right, let me start by saying Angela and Danny's wife, you guys are correct. Was it a bridesmaid's dress? Well, it was that was the inspiration when I met with Carrie, our wardrobe designer about this outfit that Pam would wear. We said,
丹尼·瑟里古德说，我妻子有一个理论，帕姆穿的那件裙子是帕姆衣柜里的一件旧伴娘礼服。丹尼，我在卡片上写了，帕姆穿伴娘礼服？问号。它看起来真的很像伴娘礼服。确实很像。是的。然后“Original Gus Girl”说，帕姆戴着手表穿礼服是谁的决定？这是一个微妙但很棒的服装和角色选择。我喜欢所有这些问题。你们太细心了。好吧，让我先说，安吉拉和丹尼的妻子，你们是对的。那是伴娘礼服吗？嗯，那是……当我与我们的服装设计师嘉莉讨论帕姆要穿的这套衣服时，那是灵感来源。我们说，
want her to be dressed up dress. But on Pam's salari about Pam's life, when w a cocktail dress and she' to buy one just for casin a whole conversation wher know what? I think she re night. So we had a whole we were like, you know wh re wears an old bridesmae
想让她穿得漂亮。但在帕姆的薪水……关于帕姆的生活，当我们……一件鸡尾酒礼服，她……为了赌场之夜买一件，我们进行了一整段对话，你知道吗？我想她真的……赌场之夜。所以我们进行了一整段对话，我们就像，你知道吗……穿一件旧伴娘礼服……
the fanciest thing she has what she wears. I'll have the first dress I tried o had a whole rack of dress all on. That was our favor picture to Greg and he approved it immediately. It was like a winner from the start. Well that is so great and perfect and really answers my burning question because I was like that I feel like I wore a bridesmaids dress that looks similar
她拥有的最华丽的东西就是她穿的。我试穿的第一件裙子……有一整排裙子……都穿上了。那是我们最喜欢的……给格雷格看了照片，他立刻批准了。它就像从一开始就是赢家。嗯，那太棒了，太完美了，真的回答了我迫切的问题，因为我当时想，我觉得我穿过一件看起来类似的伴娘礼服
to that yeah to a wedding in the 90s. By the way I love that watch question Angela because that was a discussion. It was a discussion that w because that was a discu that Pam wears that watch the time you can't see it would come up to me and h and it had my watch and i ring on it or my Pam enga you pick it up, you put i
到那个……是的，在90年代参加婚礼。顺便说一下，我喜欢那个手表的问题，安吉拉，因为那是一个讨论。那是一个讨论……因为那是一个讨论……帕姆戴着那块手表，有时候你看不到它……会走到我面前……它有我的手表，或者我的订婚戒指……你把它拿起来，你把它……
in the morning, take it o night. And so I've always been wearing that watch, but you cannot normally see it because it's underneath my sleeve, right? So we had a whole discussion, does Pam wear her watch with her fancy dress or not? And we thought, listen, guys, this is back before iPhones. You didn't have the time in your back pocket
早上，晚上摘下来。所以我一直戴着那块手表，但你通常看不到它，因为它在我的袖子下面，对吧？所以我们进行了一整段讨论，帕姆穿她的华丽礼服时戴不戴手表？我们想，听着，伙计们，这是在iPhone出现之前。你口袋里没有时间……
the way you do now. And we discussed that Pam does not have a fancy watch. So she's got one watch and she wore it. And I can't believe someone noticed that detail. Thanks for noticing. Pam would wear her watch. That made such sense to me. I love it.
像你现在这样。我们讨论过帕姆没有名表。所以她只有一块手表，她就戴着它。我不敢相信有人注意到了那个细节。谢谢你的注意。帕姆会戴她的手表。这对我来说很有意义。我喜欢它。
I feel like she also probably has a pair of Keds on standby that she can change into. I love that. Angela, what about your dress? You're wearing a black dress which is in your color scheme but I mean it's a it's a little bit it's a bit what sultry it's somewhat tight. It's an LBD for sure it is a little black dress I, I have a little bit of cleavage. Yeah, a little bit. A little bit. It is a tight little black dress. I feel like she probably wore it to a funeral and maybe it had some lace attachment over her decollage. But maybe she's feeling a little a little
我觉得她可能还有一双Keds运动鞋备用，可以换上。我喜欢那个。安吉拉，你的裙子呢？你穿了一件黑色的裙子，这在你的色系里，但我的意思是，它有点……它有点……性感，它有点紧。它绝对是一件小黑裙，它是一件小黑裙。我，我有一点乳沟。是的，一点点。一点点。这是一件紧身的小黑裙。我觉得她可能是穿去参加葬礼的，也许她的领口上有一些蕾丝装饰。但也许她感觉有点……有点
saucy. So she was like, I'm not gonna wear this sweater that goes with it. I do have a sweater that comes in and out of scenes I don't know if you notice at right at the top I'm holding it and then later on you see me wearing it but um yeah I know I'm wearing a little black dress. I have to point out it's jumping around but I have a great catch of someone breaking character. Oh and that's someone is me at 13 minutes 24 seconds there is a shot of Angela Martin talking to Meredith and you see at the very beginning of the moment maybe I'm aware that camera's panning over and so I have a solemn look and then clearly I think camera has gone off of us and then
俏皮。所以她就像，我不打算穿那件配套的毛衣。我确实有一件毛衣在场景中穿进穿出，我不知道你有没有注意到，在最开始我拿着它，然后后来你看到我穿着它，但是……嗯，是的，我知道我穿着一件小黑裙。我必须指出，虽然跳跃得有点多，但我有一个很棒的捕捉到有人出戏的镜头。哦，那个人是我，在13分24秒，有一个安吉拉·马丁和梅雷迪思说话的镜头，你在那一刻的最开始看到，也许我意识到摄像机正在扫过，所以我有一个严肃的表情，然后很明显我认为摄像机已经离开了我们，然后
I just go I just like start gesturing and I think I can make out the words I have to pee or something. Oh my gosh, what else is going on? Are you in the background of another scene? I'm in the background of an establishing shot of you and Roy gambling. And then it pans over to the rest of us.
我只是……我只是开始做手势，我想我可以辨认出“我得去尿尿”之类的词。哦，天哪，还有什么在发生？你在另一个场景的背景里吗？我在你和罗伊赌博的一个建立镜头背景里。然后它扫向了我们其他人。
Jim's at another table, I'm talking to Meredith, I'm holding my sweater an of it, I have a solemn fa seconds, I think the camera start being chatty. It's Oh my gosh. All right, sh now, let's get into it. C chips. Carol has arrived.
吉姆在另一张桌子，我在和梅雷迪思说话，我拿着我的毛衣……我有一个严肃的脸……秒，我想摄像机开始变得健谈。哦，天哪。好的，现在，让我们开始吧。筹码。卡罗尔到了。
wingman, I guess. And Toby at cards. Yes. And I have arrive. Dwight is Michael and Toby just beat Michael and I have a few fan quest The first one comes from She says Dwight is a terr inability to warn Michael is great. Was any of that So I looked at the script and You know when Carol first arrives and Dwight comes up and says code remax is here But no sign of land Jevinson. Yeah, it's so good. That second part was improvised
僚机，我想。还有托比在玩牌。是的。我到了。德怀特是迈克尔，托比刚刚打败了迈克尔，我有几个粉丝问题。第一个来自……她说德怀特是一个可怕的……无法警告迈克尔真是太棒了。那是真的吗？所以我看了剧本，你知道当卡罗尔第一次到达时，德怀特走过来说“代码Remax在这里”，但没有兰·杰文森的踪迹。是的，太棒了。那第二部分是即兴创作的。
So I'm not sure I know I'm not sure brain did it or if it was like one of the writer pitches on set because we would have writers on set That would pitch us jokes not your brain did it or of the writer pitches on have writers on set that jokes. But the original l be no sign of date number very funny because it is also out loud. He says Mi All right. So Jenna at 18
所以我不太确定，我知道我不确定是布莱恩做的，还是现场编剧提出的建议之一，因为我们会有编剧在现场，他们会给我们提建议……不是你布莱恩做的，或者编剧在现场……笑话。但最初的……没有日期编号的踪迹，非常有趣，因为它也是大声说出来的。他说迈克尔……好的。所以珍娜，在18分……
I have a card called kiss Oh, this is a classic. Th Angela moment. It's when crafts and Angela walks u dress and she's like, wha they're very formal with very formal and he's like to roll an eight and everyone wins. And she says, so roll an eight.
我有一张叫“吻”的牌。哦，这是一个经典。那个安吉拉时刻。那是当……和安吉拉走过来……裙子，她就像，什么……他们非常正式，非常正式，他说，掷出一个8，每个人都赢。她说，那就掷出一个8。
And then he does. Yes! And he is so excited that he grabs you and he kisses you on the cheek. I know! And listen, even though maybe she's happy about that, she has to slap him for being inappropriate at work. Yes. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Heather Lindo. Sam, will you play it?
然后他真的掷出了。是的！他太兴奋了，他抓住你，亲了你的脸颊。我知道！听着，即使她可能对此感到高兴，她也必须打他一巴掌，因为他在工作中不恰当。是的。嗯，安吉拉，我们收到了希瑟·林多的粉丝提问。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？
Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Casino Night is one of my very favorite episodes for a lot of reasons. And one of them being the scene at the craps table when Dwight kisses Angela for good luck, and then she slaps him. but when she turns around her face is just perfection. She cycles through like 10 emotions in a matter of like three seconds. She is horrified and thrilled and embarrassed and obviously deep down very happy all at the same time and I just love it. And Angela, my question is did you nail that on the first take or did you have to do it many, many times?
嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。赌场之夜是我最喜欢的剧集之一，原因有很多。其中之一就是掷骰子桌上的那一幕，德怀特为了好运亲了安吉拉，然后她打了他一巴掌。但当她转过身时，她的表情简直完美。她在三秒钟内循环了大约10种情绪。她感到震惊、兴奋、尴尬，显然内心深处非常高兴，所有这些都在同一时间。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，我的问题是，你是第一条就拍好了，还是不得不拍了很多很多次？
Thank you so much for letting me ask my question. I know everyone says this, but my sister Kim and I really are the Office number one fans. We just love you so much, so thank you. Oh my God, Heather! That was so sweet, I love that question so much. Okay, so I was very excited about this question because I actually wrote in my journal about the scene, of course you did. Of course we did I wrote about it the week we filmed it to answer your question Heather
非常感谢你让我问我的问题。我知道每个人都这么说，但我姐姐金和我真的是《办公室》的头号粉丝。我们太爱你们了，所以谢谢你们。哦，天哪，希瑟！那太甜了，我太喜欢那个问题了。好的，所以我对这个问题非常兴奋，因为我实际上在我的日记里写了关于那一幕的事，当然你写了。当然我们写了，我在我们拍摄的那一周写了它，来回答你的问题，希瑟。
No, I did not get it right the first time. Okay, so I wrote that I was really nervous to slap rain at first You know, my slap was kind of timid which makes sense because you were probably very you were worried about hurting him slap was kind of timid, w you were probably very, y about hurting him. Exactly hurt him and it wasn't a told you to really slap h were never did a phony sl
不，我没有第一次就做对。好的，所以我写道，我一开始真的很紧张，不敢打雷恩。你知道，我的巴掌有点胆怯，这很合理，因为你可能非常……你担心伤害他……巴掌有点胆怯，你可能非常……关于伤害他。完全正确，伤害他，这不是一个……告诉你真的打他……从来没有做过虚假的巴掌……
a real slap and well I gu slap wasn't working. So R just go for it. I can tak really slapping him. And I wrote that it took us about 13 takes to get home. That's 13 slots. All right. Here's the one thing I need you guys to remember. I am five one rain is like six three. So it wasn't really easy for me to reach his cheek. And one time my aim was really off and I missed his cheek and I slapped his ear so hard. He was like, I'd actually heard him. You said there was like a ringing in his ear. And then the other time I missed and I slapped and I hit his glasses
一个真正的巴掌，嗯，我想巴掌没起作用。所以雷恩说，直接来吧。我可以承受……真的打他。我写道，我们拍了大约13条才拍好。那是13个巴掌。好的。有一件事我需要你们记住。我身高五英尺一，雷恩大约六英尺三。所以对我来说要够到他的脸颊并不容易。有一次我的瞄准真的偏了，我错过了他的脸颊，我狠狠地打了他的耳朵。他就像，我真的伤害了他。你说就像他的耳朵里有耳鸣。然后另一次我打偏了，我打到了他的眼镜
and I knocked them sideways on his face. I know. I know. Well, I want to go back to something that Heather said too about that look on your face as you're walking away. Yeah. Because it is, it is amazing. And I have the script and I looked it up and all it says is that you slapped white and that you smile as you walk away from the table. I think there's so much more going on in your face. So your character is angry that Dwight would kiss you so publicly and all of that. But what I love is that you have this little look to the camera at the very end. It's like 18 minutes, 48 seconds. Yeah. Where you sort of catch the camera catching you smiling. That camera catch was not in the script. Was that improvised?
我把它们打得在他脸上歪了。我知道。我知道。嗯，我想回到希瑟说的关于你走开时脸上的表情。是的。因为它确实，确实很神奇。我有剧本，我查了一下，上面只写着你打了德怀特，然后你走开桌子时微笑了。我觉得你脸上还有更多的事情发生。所以你的角色很生气德怀特会如此公开地亲你，诸如此类。但我喜欢的是，你在最后对摄像机有一个小小的表情。大约18分48秒。是的。你似乎捕捉到了摄像机捕捉到你在微笑。那个摄像机捕捉不在剧本里。那是即兴创作的吗？
Yes, it was. Okay, so that just happened on the day, that little moment where I'm busted at the end. So in one of the early takes, I was walking out of frame and I just looked at camera and I quickly looked away. Like I was embarrassed that they caught me smiling. And our director of photography, Randall Einhorn said, Ange, Ange, I caught it. I caught it right at the end as you're leaving frame.
是的，是。好的，所以那只是当天发生的，那个我最后被抓包的小时刻。所以在早期的拍摄中，我正走出画面，我只是看了一眼摄像机，然后迅速移开。就像我很尴尬被他们抓到在笑。我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩说，安吉，安吉，我抓到了。我在你离开画面时最后抓到了它。
And he really helped me find that moment. Then he showed it to our director. Our director loved it. And so Randall was like, Ange, you don't have a lot of time to cycle through all that, but I'm going to catch it every time if you glance to camera and quickly look away embarrassed. So I have to thank Randall for that. Cause he really helped me make that moment happen. I love that.
他真的帮我找到了那一刻。然后他把它展示给我们的导演看。我们的导演很喜欢它。所以兰德尔说，安吉，你没有太多时间去循环所有这些情绪，但如果你瞥一眼摄像机并迅速尴尬地移开，我每次都会抓到它。所以我必须感谢兰德尔。因为他真的帮我实现了那一刻。我喜欢那个。
Yes. All right folks out there that love background catches. I have one more moment for you in this little scene at 18 minutes, 51 seconds. You can really see how red the side of Rain's face is. And it's because I have slapped him 13 times. Ha! Well, there you have it. Heather, thank you for such a great question.
是的。好的，各位喜欢背景捕捉的朋友们。在这个小场景里，在18分51秒，我还有一个时刻给你们。你可以清楚地看到雷恩脸的一侧有多红。那是因为我打了他13次。哈！好吧，就是这样。希瑟，谢谢你这么棒的问题。
Thank you, Heather. I love that question. Okay, so Angela, you just described the big kind of Dwight Angela flirt moment that happens in front of everybody at the at the casino night. So now we head over to the poker table where it is heads up between Jim and Pam. And I feel like this is the big Jim Pam flirt moment that's public. There is so much
谢谢你，希瑟。我喜欢那个问题。好的，所以安吉拉，你刚刚描述了在赌场之夜大家面前发生的德怀特和安吉拉调情的时刻。现在我们前往扑克桌，那是吉姆和帕姆之间的对决。我觉得这是公开的吉姆和帕姆调情的重大时刻。有这么多
flirting happening. Pam is basically doing the giggle hair toss move from about last night. I mean, there it is on it is so much flirting happening. is basically doing the g it is on, it is on. Well, from live love California, faces back and forth. Was between us, there was a and so what you're seeing is John and I's interpretation. This is what it says right after Jim's line. You're bluffing. Pam makes a playful gesture like who knows? Jim stares at her intensely. She smiles her best enigmatic smile. Jim enjoys this woman so much, he finally has to break eye contact and shake it off. Oh.
调情正在发生。帕姆基本上在做昨晚的那个咯咯笑甩头发的动作。我的意思是，它就在那里……有这么多调情正在发生。它就在那里，它就在那里。嗯，来自“Live Love California”，脸来回转动。在我们之间，有一个……所以你看到的是约翰和我的诠释。这是吉姆台词之后写的。你虚张声势。帕姆做了一个俏皮的手势，好像谁知道呢？吉姆盯着她看，眼神强烈。她露出了她最神秘的微笑。吉姆非常享受这个女人，他终于不得不打破眼神接触并摇摇头。哦。
So that was what John and I, we had to take that note in the script and that's what made that scene. Oh, that's so good. I love that. Yeah. I love that. Well, I have a question that's not related
所以这就是约翰和我，我们不得不接受剧本里的那个注释，这就是成就那个场景的原因。哦，那太好了。我喜欢那个。是的。我喜欢那个。嗯，我有一个问题，与
to you guys flirting, but at 19 minutes, 26 seconds, what the heck? So Kevin wears glasses when he plays poker, but he doesn't wear glasses to be an accountant. Angela, we literally got a fan question that said the same thing. What's up? My theory about that is that he doesn an accountant. I know. Bu us, he has won one of the the world series of poker player. This guy, he's a playing poker. He's a sma
你们调情无关，但在19分26秒，到底怎么回事？凯文玩扑克时戴眼镜，但他当会计时不戴眼镜。安吉拉，我们确实收到了一个粉丝问题，说了同样的话。怎么回事？我关于那个的理论是，他不……会计。我知道。但是……我们，他赢得了世界扑克系列赛选手之一。这家伙，他在玩扑克。他是一个聪明的……
playing poker. But also w in his band, he wears a h he comes to the barbecue, he's got a whol of the office that is ver what we see on a daily ba sure. I want to follow th is he, is he putting us a
玩扑克。但同时……在他的乐队里，他戴着帽子……他来参加烧烤，他有一个……办公室里非常……我们每天看到的……当然。我想跟进这个……他是，他是把我们……
really have to do work? W Okay, we have to talk abo Carol and Jan are now sid the bar. Oh yeah. Okay, we have to talk about 20 minutes, three seconds. Carol and Jan are now side by side at the bar. Oh yeah. Okay, so I took a screen grab of them standing side by side. You know I'm friends with Nancy, Steve's wife. I just adore her so much.
真的必须工作吗？好吧，我们必须谈谈……卡罗尔和简现在在吧台旁边。哦，是的。好的，我们必须谈谈20分3秒。卡罗尔和简现在在吧台并排站着。哦，是的。好的，所以我截了一张她们并排站着的图。你知道我和南希，史蒂夫的妻子是朋友。我非常崇拜她。
I texted her the photo and I'm like, Nancy, this is how I'm starting my morning. And she was like, oh my God. She said, first of all, WTF with my hair. I said, Nancy, what do you remember about shooting these scenes? And she said, oh my gosh, well, our kids were six and three. So I had very few functioning brain cells at that point. And I said, well, Nancy, what was it like working with Steve?
我给她发了那张照片，我说，南希，这就是我开始早晨的方式。她说，哦，天哪。她说，首先，我的头发是怎么回事。我说，南希，你对拍摄这些场景有什么记忆？她说，天哪，嗯，我们的孩子当时六岁和三岁。所以我当时几乎没有正常工作的脑细胞。我说，嗯，南希，和史蒂夫一起工作是什么感觉？
And she said, Ange, I was so intimidated because he's so good. I mean, he was really nice to me, of course. But I've sort of, you know, I had retired and having our kids. That's what I was doing. I was being a mom, so I felt a little rusty, but it was so much fun. Oh, she is so great. And Steve's face would just light up every time she came to set. Either if she was in a scene or if she was just coming by with the kids for a visit. I mean his adoration of her was just would go all across his face. Oh, they just were the cutest of cutie cutes as a couple.
她说，安吉，我太紧张了，因为他太棒了。我的意思是，他对我当然真的很好。但我有点，你知道，我退休了，在照顾我们的孩子。我就是这么做的。我在当妈妈，所以我感觉有点生疏，但这太有趣了。哦，她太棒了。每次她来到片场，史蒂夫的脸都会亮起来。无论是她在一个场景里，还是她只是带着孩子们过来探班。我的意思是，他对她的崇拜简直写满了他的脸。哦，他们作为一对夫妇简直是可爱中的可爱。
They are an adorable couple. They are so sweet with one another. I just loved them get so excited to when Nan scenes because we were of makeup at the same time an gab and gab and gab. I ju So now Michael is at the c
他们是一对可爱的夫妇。他们彼此之间太甜了。我只是喜欢他们……当南希……场景时，因为我们当时都在化妆，然后聊天，聊天，聊天。我只是……所以现在迈克尔在……
has both Carol and Jan blo luck. So weird, so weird, this is where Dwight starts peppering Jan with questions about where are you staying tonight? He's naming all the motels. And then Dwight has this line where he's like, Oh, were you planning to stay with Michael? Well, that was not in the script. Oh, it wasn't? No, no. I feel like that when I heard that, I went to the script to look because I'm like, that sounds like a rain improv to me. That's brilliant rain. So good. So good.
有卡罗尔和简……运气。太奇怪了，太奇怪了，这就是德怀特开始用问题轰炸简的地方，你今晚住哪儿？他列举了所有的汽车旅馆。然后德怀特有这句台词，他说，哦，你打算和迈克尔住在一起吗？嗯，那不在剧本里。哦，不在吗？不，不。我觉得当我听到那个时，我去看剧本了，因为我想，那听起来像是雷恩的即兴创作。那是天才的雷恩。太好了。太好了。
Yes. So good. I think she was legitimately surprised that he said it. Yeah, I texted Malora. I told her she's so fantastic in this episode. You just really feel Jan's desperation. And then you feel herself loathing. It's, oh, it's so layered. So now we go over to the poker table with Kevin and Phyllis. Mm-hmm. Phyllis the flapper. Phyllis the flapper.
是的。太好了。我想她确实对他说的话感到惊讶。是的，我给马洛拉发了短信。我告诉她她在这一集里太棒了。你真的能感受到简的绝望。然后你感受到她对自己的厌恶。哦，它太有层次了。所以现在我们去凯文和菲利斯的扑克桌。嗯哼。菲利斯，那个轻浮的人。菲利斯，那个轻浮的人。
Phyllis the flapper. He goes all in against Phyllis, and she wins with a flush. But she thought she only had ace high. But no, she ace and she is like, I ha I texted Phyllis and I sa you remember about that p wrote me and said, oh, I game. Brian's faces kevin
菲利斯，那个轻浮的人。他全押对抗菲利斯，她用同花赢了。但她以为她只有A高。但没有，她A，她就像，我……我给菲利斯发了短信，我说……你还记得关于那个……写信给我说，哦，我……游戏。布莱恩的脸是凯文……
won. And then she r watching Pam and Jim flir it looked real because th actors. Oh, no, she's the said it was a priceless e you and Jenna. Oh, well l what? Jan is gonna walk minutes 37 seconds because she's just over it and she's outside smoking and Jim walks out and lady I don't know
赢了。然后她……看着帕姆和吉姆调情……看起来很真实，因为他们是……演员。哦，不，她是……说这是一个无价的……你和珍娜。哦，好吧……什么？简要走开……37秒，因为她受够了，她在外面抽烟，吉姆走出来，女士，我不知道
if you remember this but at the time when this aired so many people thought that Jim and Jan were maybe going to hook up in this moment and they were freaking out on all the message boards. Oh my God. Yeah. I really like Oh, no, no. Are they gonna hook up? But no, they're just having a heart to heart. And then you find out the stakes for Jim, right? That he Yeah, she's like, have you told anyone? Because he's gonna transfer but yeah people thought they might hook up and they were all like no yeah so now we go back inside Bob Vance is making an announcement he's gonna announce who the big winner of the night is he said it's Creed Bratton okay and he wins a refrigerator and Creed says I've never owned a refrigerator oh my god this is this first one. T first refrigerator. So he
你是否记得这一点，但在播出时，很多人认为吉姆和简可能会在这一刻发生关系，他们在所有的留言板上都疯了。哦，天哪。是的。我真的很喜欢……哦，不，不。他们会发生关系吗？但没有，他们只是在进行交心。然后你发现了吉姆的赌注，对吧？他……是的，她说，你告诉过任何人吗？因为他要调职了，但是的，人们认为他们可能会发生关系，他们都说不……是的，所以现在我们回到里面，鲍勃·万斯正在宣布，他要宣布谁是当晚的大赢家，他说那是克里德·布拉顿，好的，他赢了一台冰箱，克里德说我从来没有拥有过冰箱，哦，天哪，这是第一个。第一台冰箱。所以他
we are to the jam tastic There is going to be a bi lot. There's going to be the office. So we thought john Krasinski. That's ri like we could talk about him. So's right. We didn't feel like we could talk about these scenes without him. So we did. We called him and he joined us. So guys, this is like we chitty chatted with John for a good 45 minutes. We're gonna let it play out here for you.
我们到了……精彩的时刻。将会有一个……很多。将会是办公室。所以我们想约翰·卡拉辛斯基。那是对的……就像我们可以谈论他。所以是对的。我们觉得如果不谈论这些场景就无法谈论他。所以我们做了。我们打电话给他，他加入了我们。所以伙计们，这就像我们和约翰聊了整整45分钟。我们要让它在这里为你播放。
Enjoy. Guys, I watched an office episode for the first time in so long for this. Yeah. I haven't watched one for a little while now. And that one in particular, that's some heavy machinery of content. Yeah. Yeah. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw. Yeah. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw you in the deep end, John. We were like, here, watch this one.
享受。伙计们，为了这个，我很久以来第一次看《办公室》的一集。是的。我已经有一段时间没看了。尤其是那一集，那是沉重的机器内容。是的。是的。那是沉重的机器。我们刚刚扔了。是的。那是沉重的机器。我们刚刚把你扔进了深水区，约翰。我们就像，给你，看这一集。
Yeah, seriously. And I was like, first of all, I went through a time portal. I was like, who is that child? And I was talking about Jenna. And then I saw some furry, you know, wood nymph come in looking at me. Man, we were young once, weren't we? Wasn't that nice?
是的，说真的。我当时想，首先，我穿过了一个时间隧道。我当时想，那个孩子是谁？我在说珍娜。然后我看到一些毛茸茸的，你知道，木仙女进来看着我。伙计，我们曾经年轻过，不是吗？那不是很美好吗？
Yeah. Well, man, that was nice way back then. This is the first time I've watched Casino Night since it aired. Same. Yeah. Did we watch it at Greg's? I think we did.
是的。嗯，伙计，那时候真好。这是我自《赌场之夜》播出以来第一次看它。我也是。是的。我们在格雷格家看的吗？我想我们看了。
We did. We did. I wrote in my journal that he had a viewing party and we all went over. Oh my God, do you have a journal? What am I doing with my life? Does she have a journal? Let me show you what my mic sits on so I can reach it because I'm shorty. Like seven journals. Like with Holly Hobby on the front. John, this is, that's who I was. I mean, come on. Oh my God. Wait, who you were? That seems like a current journal that is being written about right now. I'm writing right now.
我们看了。我们看了。我在我的日记里写道，他举办了一个观看派对，我们都去了。哦，天哪，你有日记？我的生活在做什么？她有日记吗？让我给你看看我的麦克风放在什么上面，这样我才能够到它，因为我很矮。像七本。封面上有Holly Hobby的那种。约翰，这是，那就是我。我的意思是，拜托。哦，天哪。等等，你是谁？那看起来像是一本正在写的当前日记。我正在写。
By the way, speaking of Polly Pocket or whatever, Holly Hobby, either one of those E's, it made me think of that kid sister thing before I signed on. I was like, I had all these like sputtering memories that were like, remember this? And I blacked out for about 20 minutes. Okay. So I told on the podcast that we would do bits between scenes, kind of keep us going, that you really kept us all going.
顺便说一下，说到Polly Pocket或者别的什么，Holly Hobby，那两个E中的任何一个，它让我想起了我在签约之前那个小妹妹的事情。我当时想，我有了所有这些像喷涌而出的记忆，就像，记得这个吗？我昏迷了大约20分钟。好的。所以我告诉播客，我们会在场景之间做一些小片段，让我们保持状态，你真的让我们所有人都保持了状态。
You really did. And then I said we would do this kid sister big brother bit. And Jenna was like, wait, where did that come from? What was that about? You're like 1983 is where it came from. I know. But it was, John, wasn't it because there was like a doll that was about my height?
你真的做到了。然后我说我们会做这个小妹妹大哥哥的片段。珍娜就像，等等，那是从哪儿来的？那是关于什么的？你就像1983年来的。我知道。但是，约翰，不是因为有一个和我身高差不多的玩偶吗？
Oh no, you were the identical replica of kid sister. And they had it was a kid was a big brother. No, no, something I would go. You I would yell around the no, there was a boy one. And then they came out with a girl one that looked exactly like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store like shelf. And I took a photo of myself standing next to it and I sent it like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store, like shelf, and I took a photo of myself standing next to it and I sent it to you.
哦不，你是小妹妹的完全复制品。他们有一个……是一个孩子……是一个大哥哥。不，不，我会去的东西。你……我会大喊大叫……不，有一个男孩的。然后他们出了一个女孩的，看起来和你一模一样。有一天我在商店里，在玩具店的货架上看到了它。我拍了一张自己站在它旁边的照片，我把它发给了……像你一样。有一天我在商店里，在玩具店的货架上看到了它，我拍了一张自己站在它旁边的照片，我把它发给了你。
You were like, oh my God. Oh, I remember that, yes. But also you're the exact size of it, compared to me especially, you're like the perfect. And I remember one day, didn't you do like the stiff arms and stuff? And I like picked you up and you were like, yeah, oh, it was great.
你就像，哦，天哪。哦，我记得那个，是的。但你也是它的大小，特别是和我相比，你就像完美的。我记得有一天，你不是做了那种僵硬的手臂之类的吗？我像把你抱起来，你就像，是的，哦，那太棒了。
It was good times. Someone, a fan wrote in and said, if you ever came on, could you and I do the bit? And I was like, well, I it's a pretty kid sister. Big brother. Oh, there it is. There it is. Jenna, what jokes did we have? We didn't get along well. What was it for us? Oh, boy. What were our bits?
那是美好的时光。有人，一个粉丝写信说，如果你曾经来过，你和我能做那个片段吗？我当时想，嗯，我……这是一个相当小妹妹。大哥哥。哦，它在那儿。它在那儿。珍娜，我们有什么笑话？我们相处得不好。那是为了我们什么？哦，天哪。我们的片段是什么？
What were our bits? What were our bits? Did we have bits? Boy, we had so many bits. You know what I remember bits-wise was many different inside jokes of like writing on Post-It notes and like all my memos that I had to hand to you for corporate, always had something written on them.
我们的片段是什么？我们的片段是什么？我们有片段吗？伙计，我们有这么多片段。你知道我记得关于片段的是许多不同的内部笑话，比如在便利贴上写字，我必须交给你的所有备忘录，总是写着什么。
John, you played one prank on me in the whole nine years of the office. Like, one, like, really fully formed, good, thought-out prank. It was at Shroot Farms, and you and I had this scene where we had to drive up to the farmhouse several times.
约翰，你在《办公室》的九年里只对我搞过一次恶作剧。就像，一次，真正完全形成、好的、深思熟虑的恶作剧。那是在施鲁特农场，你和我有一个场景，我们必须多次开车去农舍。
And we're doing it, and I am getting increasingly more hot. I'm, like like warm. I'm sweating. I'm like, oh my god. I'm like, you're so hot. And we had to turn off the AC for sound and you were like, yeah, I don't know. I'm okay, but you're hot, huh? And I'm like, I'm so hot. This went on for like 15 minutes and then all of a sudden you start snickering and you had turned on my seat warmer all the way to the hottest setting. Oh my god, that was late in the run, wasn't it? That was late in the run. And I, but I was so excited because whenever we would go on
我们正在做，我变得越来越热。我，就像……温暖。我在出汗。我当时想，哦，天哪。我当时想，你太热了。我们不得不为了声音关掉空调，你就像，是的，我不知道。我还可以，但你很热，对吧？我当时想，我太热了。这持续了大约15分钟，然后突然你开始窃笑，你把我的座椅加热器开到了最热的档位。哦，天哪，那是在后期，对吧？那是在后期。而且我，但我太兴奋了，因为每当我们去
talk shows, they would always ask us if we played pranks on each other. And I would always say no. And I mean, say no and I mean not really I mean besides just like little jokes on post-it notes or something. I'm terrible. Not really. I'm terrible at pranks. We weren't pranky you know but then finally after you did that in the car I was like oh my gosh this is great I can finally have a prank to talk about.
脱口秀节目，他们总是问我们是否互相搞恶作剧。我总是说不。我的意思是，说不，我的意思是并不是真的，我的意思是除了像便利贴上的小笑话之类的。我很糟糕。并不是真的。我不擅长恶作剧。我们不是那种爱搞恶作剧的人，你知道，但最后在你车里做了那个之后，我当时想，哦，天哪，这太棒了，我终于有一个恶作剧可以谈论了。
Are you sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank? I realized that I'm such a bad prankster that I stole that prank from Clooney when we were doing Leatherheads. He did that to me. So that's how unoriginal I am.
你对那个恶作剧感到难过吗？那个恶作剧有什么可难过的？那个恶作剧有什么可难过的？我意识到我是一个如此糟糕的恶作剧者，以至于我在我们拍《皮头》时从克鲁尼那里偷了那个恶作剧。他对我做了那个。所以这就是我有多么缺乏原创性。
I was like, I'm going to take George Clooney's bat and do it to Jenna. And I thought that would make me cool. So basically, you're that. You got Clooney is what you got. I did one degree of separation. I think that prank just keeps getting cooler.
我当时想，我要拿乔治·克鲁尼的球棒对珍娜做。我以为那会让我很酷。所以基本上，你就是那个。你得到的是克鲁尼。我做了一度分离。我觉得那个恶作剧越来越酷了。
Like that's pretty fancy. I think so too, yeah. That's a good prank. Let's get into the meat of your interview here, John. I thought we were doing pretty good. We were, but we should intro you a little. John, thank you so much for coming on the show. We always like to ask our guests a little bit about how they came to be on The Office. And I
就像那很花哨。我也这么认为，是的。那是一个好的恶作剧。让我们进入你采访的实质内容，约翰。我觉得我们做得相当不错。我们是，但我们应该稍微介绍一下你。约翰，非常感谢你来到节目。我们总是喜欢问我们的嘉宾一点关于他们是如何来到《办公室》的。而且我
know you've told this story like a million times, but is it true that you were originally asked to audition for Dwight? Yes, I was. And that reminds me that about six seasons into the show someone was like I love how you say Dwight and I was like, how do you say it? And they were like Dwight and I was like, I know Dwight and they were like, nope Dwight and I was like, no, no, I'm saying it right. It's Dwight and they were like, nope It's not so um, yes I auditioned or no I was offered to come in and audition for the role of Dwight and I
知道你讲过这个故事一百万次了，但你最初被要求试镜德怀特是真的吗？是的，我是。这让我想起，在剧集播到第六季左右时，有人说我喜欢你发“德怀特”这个词的方式，我当时想，你怎么发音？他们说“德怀特”，我当时想，我知道“德怀特”，他们说，不，“德怀特”，我当时想，不，不，我发音是对的。是“德怀特”，他们说，不，不是。所以……嗯，是的，我试镜了，或者不，我被邀请来试镜德怀特这个角色，我
was so excited. I had met Alison Jones randomly out in LA on a general meeting when I had zero dollars to my name and she said something's coming on our first meeting, our only meeting. She said something's coming called The Office. She'd be great for it. I said great. So then I got back to New York and they said, there's this show called The Office. And I was like, oh my God, Alison Jones, the greatest human ever told me about this. And they said, you're going in for the role of Dwight. And I had been a huge fan of the British show.
太兴奋了。我在洛杉矶的一次一般会议上偶然遇到了艾莉森·琼斯，当时我名下只有零美元，她说我们第一次会议，也是唯一一次会议，即将有一些事情发生。她说有一些事情叫《办公室》。她会很适合它。我说太好了。然后我回到纽约，他们说，有一个节目叫《办公室》。我当时想，哦，天哪，艾莉森·琼斯，有史以来最伟大的人告诉过我这个。他们说，你要去试镜德怀特这个角色。我一直是英国版节目的超级粉丝。
And I was like, I don't know, man. That's not, I don't know if I'm right for that role. And so I weirdly have no idea what I was thinking. I said, you know what? I read the thinking. I said, you know what? I read the pilot and I said, you know what, I'm gonna put my best foot forward. Let me know when they're casting Jims. And I remember the response from the NBC casting director
我当时想，我不知道，伙计。那不是，我不知道我是否适合那个角色。所以我奇怪地不知道我在想什么。我说，你知道吗？我读了……思考。我说，你知道吗？我读了试播集，我说，你知道吗，我要尽我所能。当他们选吉姆时告诉我。我记得NBC选角导演的反应
to my manager at the time was, no, but honestly, who does he think he is? Like passing up an audition, an opportunity to audition. And lo and behold, I thought it was over. And I think it was like five, six weeks later that they called and they were like all right they're looking for Jim's now and they'll have you back and then my gosh crazy and then when we finally did our screen test you you were living in New York and you had to fly to LA for that screen test with all these New Yorkers that were auditioning,
对我当时的经理说，不，但老实说，他以为他是谁？就像放弃试镜，放弃试镜的机会。结果，我以为结束了。我想大约五、六周后，他们打电话说，好的，他们现在在找吉姆，他们会让你回来，然后天哪，太疯狂了，然后当我们最终进行屏幕测试时，你住在纽约，你不得不飞到洛杉矶进行屏幕测试，和所有这些正在试镜的纽约人一起，
which was so much fun. I remember I took the plane with Jim Gaffigan, who was auditioning for a role and was like laughing. I mean, just was surrounded by heroes on the plane and then got to the callback or the test or whatever they called it. Cause I'm so experienced now, I have no idea what I'm talking about. But I remember getting in this big room
这太有趣了。我记得我和吉姆·加菲根一起坐飞机，他正在试镜一个角色，当时在笑。我的意思是，飞机上到处都是英雄，然后到了回调或测试，或者他们叫它什么。因为我现在太有经验了，我不知道我在说什么。但我记得进入这个大房间
and it was the waiting room of where we actually shot our pilot. I'm sure you guys have covered that, but like where we shot our pilot is what they measured down to the quarter inch or centimeter to make our set, this building that existed. We took an existing building. And I remember sitting basically where like Ryan's desk, no, like where Mindy's desk was, like Toby and Mindy's
那是我们拍摄试播集时的候机室。我相信你们肯定聊过这个，但我们拍摄试播集的地方，是他们精确到四分之一英寸或厘米来搭建布景的地方，那是一栋真实存在的建筑。我们利用了一栋现有的建筑。我记得我当时基本上坐在瑞安的办公桌位置，不，应该是明迪的办公桌位置，就像托比和明迪的
desk was. I was sitting against that wall and I saw all these other people coming in. I'd been there for like an hour or two hours and all the other people were the LA people. I realized they had separated us. And so they were asking the New York people to leave after they were done. And then I was the last New York person. And I saw all these LA people in and I started to get super self-conscious. I am not a confident person. And I was like, oh my God, this is so embarrassing. I'm the only New Yorker here. Because everybody was like, hey, Johnny, Tim, like greeting each other. And I was sitting on a floor. Like, so I went on to the set because all the producers were hiding in the background
办公桌那样。我靠着那面墙坐着，看着其他人都进来了。我在那儿待了一两个小时，其他所有人都是洛杉矶本地人。我意识到他们把我们分开了。他们要求纽约来的人在结束后离开。我是最后一个纽约人。我看到那些洛杉矶人进来，开始感到非常局促不安。我不是一个自信的人。我当时想，天哪，这太尴尬了。我是这里唯一的纽约人。因为每个人都在打招呼，嘿，强尼，蒂姆，互相问候。而我坐在地板上。所以我去了片场，因为所有的制片人都躲在背景里
and I said I'm so sorry I think someone forgot to tell me to go home and from behind a like fake wall I remember hearing like a lot of chair moving and stuff and like banging against the wall and it was Greg trying to get out of his chair and find the entrance to get back on set and he was like no hold on one second hold on one second please hold on one second and I heard Terry Weinberg being like, no, no, no, no, no, don't go. And then I went back out to the waiting room, super freaked out, and I saw Jenna walk in the door.
我说，真抱歉，我想有人忘了告诉我该回家了。从一堵假墙后面，我记得听到很多挪动椅子的声音，还有撞到墙的声音，那是格雷格正试图从椅子上站起来，寻找回到片场的入口。他说，不，等一下，等一下，请等一下。我听到特里·温伯格说，不，不，不，别走。然后我回到候机室，吓坏了，看到珍娜走了进来。
And she was like, as soon as I saw you walk in, Jen, I know I've told the story of building time, so people are like, we get it. We've seen behind the scenes. I genuinely had like a metaphysical event where I was like, oh, that's who's in the show. That person will be in the show. And so they held me back. You went in with a bunch of people. And I remember thinking, if I don't go in with her, I'm screwed. And that's when I went on the thing and said, you should let me go. And they said, no, no, no, there's one more person we want
她说，我一看到你走进来，珍，我知道我已经讲过关于搭建时间的故事了，所以人们会说，我们懂了。我们看过幕后花絮。我真的经历了一次形而上的事件，当时我想，哦，那就是剧里的人。那个人会出现在剧里。所以他们留住了我。你和一群人一起进去了。我记得当时想，如果我不和她一起进去，我就完蛋了。就在那时，我走过去说，你应该让我进去。他们说，不，不，还有一个人我们想
you to audition with. And it was you. And I thought, oh my god, you're saying there's a chance because if I'm in with you, I knew I had a shot. Oh my god, John, I can go back to that moment that I saw you at the audition and I had that exact same reaction. I, it was, I've tried to describe it to people, like what it was like to audition with you. And the best, like the best explanation I could come up with was like, what if you walked into a room and music started playing and you and another person just started dancing in unison, even though you'd never met. That's what it was like auditioning with you. Wow, that's really way more beautiful than what I would say, which is like, I felt like I could see the future.
让你试镜。那就是你。我想，天哪，你说还有机会，因为如果我和你一起，我就知道我有戏了。天哪，约翰，我能回到那个我在试镜时看到你的瞬间，我当时也有完全一样的反应。我，我试着向人们描述和你一起试镜是什么感觉。我能想到的最好的解释是，如果你走进一个房间，音乐开始响起，你和另一个人就开始同步跳舞，尽管你们从未见过面。和你一起试镜就是那种感觉。哇，那真的比我要说的美多了，我会说，我感觉自己能看到未来。
I was like, it actually gave me anxiety because I was like, she's so on the show. It's so weird that I'm like watching a piece get in. And I remember, I'm sure you remember too, but went after our audition and I loved auditioning with you. We were walking through the kitchen. And I said, because that was the way out. And I said, I just got to let you know,
我当时想，这甚至让我感到焦虑，因为我觉得，她太适合这部剧了。我看着一个拼图碎片归位，这感觉太奇怪了。我记得，我相信你也记得，试镜结束后，我很喜欢和你一起试镜。我们穿过厨房。我说，因为那是出口。我说，我只是想让你知道，
I think that you're going to get this part. You're perfect for this. And you seem to remember, you said the same thing to me. I don't, because I blacked out. I was trying to not look you in the eyes. I did. I was so excited that you said that, because I felt like I had wanted to say that to you,
我觉得你会得到这个角色。你太适合了。你似乎记得，你也对我说了同样的话。我不记得了，因为我断片了。我当时尽量不看你的眼睛。我确实说了。你那么说让我非常兴奋，因为我觉得我一直想对你说，
but I didn't have the courage. Because I didn't know you, you were like essentially a stranger to me. The only time we had really spoken or interacted was during our audition. So we were kind of silently walking back to the kitchen and I was thinking in my head, should I tell him I think he's the best gym?
但我没有勇气。因为我不认识你，你对我来说基本上是个陌生人。我们真正交谈或互动的唯一一次就是在试镜期间。所以我们当时默默地走回厨房，我心里在想，我该告诉他我觉得他是最好的吉姆吗？
Is that appropriate? Should I say you're the best gym, you're gonna be gym? Or is that bad form? I don't know, what's the etiquette? And so when you said, I think you're gonna best gym, you're going to be gym? Or is that bad form? I don't know, what's the etiquette? And so when you said, I think you're going to get the role of Pam, my memory is that I was like, oh my God, I think you're going to be gym,
这样合适吗？我该说你是最好的吉姆，你会成为吉姆吗？还是说这样不好？我不知道，礼仪是什么？所以当你说了，我觉得你会得到帕姆这个角色时，我的记忆是，我当时想，天哪，我觉得你会成为吉姆，
you're the best gym, you're my favorite gym. Like that I just like blurted, I had like this just- Yeah, I was having a nosebleed at that time, don't remember much. But I do remember this though, that, you know, I always say this and people are like, yeah, whatever, but it's true. I have a lottery ticket life ever since I was given the news that I was on that show.
你是最好的吉姆，你是我最喜欢的吉姆。就像我脱口而出，我当时只是——是的，那时我流鼻血了，记不太清了。但我确实记得这一点，你知道，我总是这么说，人们会说，好吧，随便吧，但这是真的。自从我得到我出演那部剧的消息后，我的人生就像中了彩票一样。
Everything changed in my life from every single way, not to get into a heady version, but like not only every opportunity that I've ever had is from the show. I met my wife because she knew who I was in a restaurant for a show. We never would have been in the same city or restaurant or anything. It was, it's just so crazy how deep and crazy it goes. But I remember at the epicenter of it all, when I was told that I had the part, I actually jumped on a couch. And then like, like, again, this metaphysical thing came over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second. Um, did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam? And they were like, over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second. Did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam?
我生活中的一切都发生了改变，不仅仅是每一个我得到的机会都来自这部剧。我遇到了我的妻子，因为她在一家餐馆里认出了我是那个剧里的人。我们永远不会在同一个城市或餐馆相遇。这太疯狂了，它影响得如此深远。但我记得在这一切的中心，当我被告知我得到了这个角色时，我实际上跳到了沙发上。然后，就像，再次，这种形而上的感觉笼罩了我，我问，等等，等等，一秒钟。嗯，珍娜·费舍尔得到帕姆的角色了吗？他们说，
And they were like, we don't know. We just told you your life changed. Are you happy enough with that? And I was like, no, you need to call them back and ask if Jenna got the part. Cause I thought if you were on it, then I was going to be on one of the best things that I'll ever do in my life.
他们说，我们不知道。我们只是告诉你你的生活改变了。你对此足够高兴吗？我说，不，你们需要回电问问珍娜是否得到了角色。因为我想如果你在剧里，那么我将参与我一生中做过的最棒的事情之一。
And if they were like, no, you know, Rhonda something whatever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when, whatever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when they called me and told me that I got the part, I had a very similar reaction. And the first question I asked was, did John Krasinski get the role of Jim? Because I just felt like, I don't know if I can do Pam without you as Jim. So I was like, I need to know, did my, did my partner in crime get this part? And they were like, yes, he did.
如果他们说，不，你知道，某个叫朗达的人得到了。我会说，不，不是朗达。好吧，当他们打电话告诉我我得到了角色时，我有过非常相似的反应。我问的第一个问题是，约翰·卡拉辛斯基得到吉姆的角色了吗？因为我只是觉得，我不知道没有你作为吉姆，我该怎么演帕姆。所以我说，我需要知道，我的犯罪同伙得到这个角色了吗？他们说，是的，他得到了。
And what's weird is that that's the first question he asked after he was told. He asked- And by the way, we never saw each other after the kitchen. I left. No, we didn't have each other's phone numbers. We couldn't text each other or email.
奇怪的是，那是他被告知后问的第一个问题。他问——顺便说一句，我们在厨房之后就再也没见过面。我离开了。不，我们没有对方的电话号码。我们不能发短信或发邮件。
So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited each other or email. So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited. Same with Rain. I only met Rain at the audition. And when I heard he got the role, I was like, well, that tracks because he was definitely the weirdest dude. Oh my god.
所以就像，我只是等到试播集剧本围读时，我们才重聚。雷恩也是。我只在试镜时见过雷恩。当我听说他得到了角色时，我想，好吧，这很合理，因为他绝对是最奇怪的家伙。天哪。
I remember thinking, I remember doing this audition with Rain where Greg asked me to ask him to cover my phones and of course he said to Rain under no circumstances will you cover his phones and I remember being like hey Dwight will you just cover my phone I just got to go to the bathroom and he was like sorry and then pretended to close barn doors and then I asked him again and he did like like shipping container doors and I kept doing it. And by the end of it, not to Dwight, to the actor Rain, I was like, you are infuriating. You're an infuriating human.
我记得我当时和雷恩一起试镜，格雷格让我叫他帮我接电话，当然他告诉雷恩无论如何都不要接他的电话。我记得我说，嘿，德怀特，你能帮我接一下电话吗？我得去趟洗手间。他说，抱歉。然后假装关上谷仓门。我又问了他一次，他做了像集装箱门那样的动作，我一直不停地问。到最后，不是对德怀特，而是对演员雷恩，我说，你真让人抓狂。你是一个让人抓狂的人。
And I was like, he's gonna get it. Well, oh my gosh. It's so good to talk to you. All of that just makes my heart happy, you guys. Hearing all that, I don't know that I've, you know, I've heard snippets of those stories, but I've never heard all of it and watched you guys tell it is actually really beautiful just go no I was gonna say I've
我当时想，他肯定会被选上。好吧，天哪。和你聊天真好。所有这些都让我的心感到快乐，伙计们。听到这一切，我不知道我是否，你知道，我听过这些故事的片段，但我从未听过完整版，看着你们讲述这些故事真的很美。不，我本来想说我
actually never told those stories with you in I was gonna say in person or not in digital form the same I feel like we've told those stories separately on talk shows or interviews, but actually never to one another. Yeah, it's like there's always these things where you're like, is that what happened? It's so interesting. So amazing. I have so many stories that I'm like, I wonder if people know that.
其实从来没有和你们一起讲过这些故事，我是说当面，或者不是以数字形式。我觉得我们分别在脱口秀或采访中讲过这些故事，但从来没有对彼此讲过。是的，总是有这些事情，你会想，那是当时发生的事吗？太有趣了。太神奇了。我有很多故事，我都在想，不知道人们知不知道。
It's like some of my favorite stuff is like sort of, I guess it's a secret, but I don't know. Oh, like one of my favorite stories I ever tell you this story was when we wrapped by the way how dare Greg Daniels do that rap remember that when he was like yeah I just got to get you guys leave in the office a couple times for I got to cut it into the earlier part of the show and we were all just totally goofing off and laughing heading to like for Richard is like and then when we came back he was standing there
就像我最喜欢的一些东西，我想这算是个秘密，但我不知道。哦，比如我最喜欢的故事之一，我有没有给你讲过这个故事，就是我们杀青的时候，顺便说一句，格雷格·丹尼尔斯怎么敢那样做，记得吗？他说，是的，我只需要你们在办公室里离开几次，我得把它剪进剧集的前半部分。我们当时完全在胡闹，大笑，走向理查德，然后当我们回来时，他站在那里
all weird remember that yeah and it was like that that was the last take of anything he was like ladies and gentlemen I just want to tell you that the show has concluded or the office is over that's a wrap that's a wrap and I was like and I definitely threw up on my shoes someone took a picture of that moment I don't know who it was but we're all getting that picture we're disintegrating we're like all of us't know who it was, but we're all disintegrating. We're like all of us. It was like some weird, incredibly smart move to like,
样子很奇怪，记得吗？是的，那是最后一条拍摄。他说，女士们先生们，我只想告诉你们，这部剧已经结束了，或者说《办公室》结束了，杀青了。杀青了。我当时想，我绝对吐在鞋子上了。有人拍下了那一刻，我不知道是谁，但我们都拿到了那张照片。我们正在崩溃，我们就像我们所有人。这就像某种奇怪的、极其聪明的举动，
just, cause we all knew it was coming. And then he did the smartest thing by being like, oh shoot, I got to do this one more thing. Like just get out of the office, walk a couple of times. I just need you to exit. And I remember Randall being weird, so he must've been in on it. And then when Greg came out, I remember we looked in all the crew. Everyone that had been in Video Village had come out on the stage.
只是，因为我们都知道它要来了。然后他做了最聪明的事，他说，哦，糟了，我得再做这一件事。就像离开办公室，走几次。我只需要你们离开。我记得兰德尔表现得很奇怪，所以他一定参与其中了。然后当格雷格出来时，我记得我们看向所有的工作人员。所有在视频村的人都来到了舞台上。
And they were all sort of. That's right. Yeah. And I was just like, what's happening? We all ended like together. Like it was so intense. It was like, I'm your dad and I'm leaving you. And you're like, what? Um, but the funny thing was that day. It was like, I'm your dad and I'm leaving you. And you're like, what? But the funny thing was that day, everybody was really emotional and we had the wrap party. And so everybody was like trying to get themselves together.
他们都在某种程度上。没错。是的。我当时只是想，发生了什么？我们最终都在一起了。这太强烈了。就像，我是你的父亲，我要离开你了。你当时想，什么？嗯，但有趣的是那天。每个人都很情绪化，我们举行了杀青派对。所以每个人都在试图让自己振作起来。
And I think of myself as a somewhat moral person. And I had the weirdest idea when I got back to the trailer, I was crying like crazy. And I went, oh, my God, there's one thing I want. If like, like, what's the one thing you would want from the show. And I ran back and stole the Dunder Mifflin sign that we all did talking head suit. And I got, dude, and then I think, I think I did tell you Jenna, cause I was like, so Catholic. I was like, must tell someone.
我觉得自己是一个有道德的人。当我回到拖车时，我有一个最奇怪的想法，我哭得厉害。我说，天哪，有一件事我想要。如果，就像，你从这部剧里最想要的一样东西是什么。我跑回去偷了我们所有人做访谈时用的邓德·米夫林标志。我拿到了，伙计，然后我想，我想我确实告诉过你，珍娜，因为我当时太天主教徒了。我想，必须告诉某人。
And then we got to the party and I'll never forgive myself. I don't even know if he knows it. We're at the party and I saw Greg and I was like, Greg, thank you for my whole life and like whatever. And he was like, yeah, yeah, no problem. And I was like, how you doing? He goes, I'm good, you know, I'm a little bummed. The one thing I wanted was the Dunder Mifflin sign. He goes, but someone took it.
然后我们到了派对上，我永远不会原谅自己。我甚至不知道他知不知道。我们在派对上，我看到了格雷格，我说，格雷格，谢谢你给了我整个人生，等等。他说，是的，是的，没问题。我说，你怎么样？他说，我很好，你知道，我有点沮丧。我唯一想要的就是邓德·米夫林标志。他说，但有人把它拿走了。
And literally my brain exploded and I went, that sucks, man. Whoever did that, that sucks. I remember saying to him, I lied to my dad. I lied to my TV creator. Oh my god. I lied to his face. I remember you loading out your trailer and I walked out and I have a visual of you putting it in your car. It was very large.
我的大脑瞬间爆炸了，我说，那太糟糕了，伙计。不管是谁干的，那太糟糕了。我记得我对他说，我对我父亲撒了谎。我对我电视节目的创作者撒了谎。天哪。我当面撒了谎。我记得你从拖车里搬东西出来，我走出来，我有一个你把它放进车的画面。它非常大。
That's how I knew. That's how I knew. Because I only had like a bath towel and that didn't even begin to cover it. It was just like, it was the worst heist of all time. And I also remember people being like, why is John leaving so fast? And I was like, don't look at me! Like as I drove out of the parking lot, it was so weird. Do you remember the big sign that, well, it was like a fake painting of me looking angry that hung in the senator's house. Oh yeah. The art department gave that to me.
那就是我怎么知道的。那就是我怎么知道的。因为我只有一条浴巾，那根本遮不住它。这就像，这是史上最糟糕的抢劫。我也记得人们在问，为什么约翰走得那么快？我说，别看我！当我开车离开停车场时，这太奇怪了。你还记得那个大标志吗，嗯，那是一幅我看起来很生气的假画，挂在参议员家里。哦，是的。艺术部门把它给了我。
It's enormous. It's the size of a small loveseat sofa. If we're sharing secrets, I'll say that I asked if I could have Pam's watercolor of Dunder Mifflin. And I was told officially from production that I could not have it because it was gonna be cataloged as part of like the set decoration and it would be stored at NBC.
它巨大无比。它有一个小型双人沙发那么大。如果我们分享秘密，我会说我问过我能不能要帕姆那幅邓德·米夫林的画。制作组正式告诉我，我不能要它，因为它会被编目为布景装饰的一部分，并存放在NBC。
And no, I couldn't have it. I was really heartbroken because besides a couple of trinkets on my desk and like a few pieces of wardrobe, I really hadn't saved anything else. That was really the one thing I wanted. And oh my gosh, I'm gonna cry a little bit. As I was leaving, Phil Shea ran up to me and he said,
不，我不能要。我真的很心碎，因为除了桌子上的一些小饰品和几件戏服，我真的没留下任何东西。那真的是我唯一想要的东西。天哪，我要哭了。当我离开时，菲尔·谢跑向我，他说，
here, you should have this. I made a color photo of it. They'll never know. I have the original in my house. Oh my it? Oh my God! That's amazing. Dude, Phil Shea is the reason I have anything. He sent me a box like years, like three or four years later, of my bag, my nameplate. Your satchel that you would carry?
给你，你应该拥有这个。我拍了一张彩色照片。他们永远不会知道。原件在我家里。天哪！那太棒了！伙计，菲尔·谢是我拥有任何东西的原因。三四年后，他寄给我一个盒子，里面有我的包，我的名牌。你平时背的那个挎包？
Yeah, my satchel, my nameplate, and the teapot, bro. You have the teapot! You have the teapot! You have the teapot! We have been wondering who has the teapot! You have the teapot! You have the teapot! We have been wondering who has the teapot! Teapot son! Son of a gun! Wow!
是的，我的挎包，我的名牌，还有茶壶，兄弟。你有那个茶壶！你有那个茶壶！你有那个茶壶！我们一直想知道谁拿走了茶壶！你有那个茶壶！你有那个茶壶！我们一直想知道谁拿走了茶壶！茶壶小子！天哪！哇！
Oh man, I thought you knew that! I didn't know it was a great caper! She said, I have always wondered who got that teapot! You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot? I've always wondered. You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot episode and I was going to take a picture of it in my room and totally forgot. I wanted to like post it right after I had heard your episode.
天哪，我以为你知道！我不知道这是一个伟大的骗局！她说，我一直想知道谁拿到了那个茶壶！你知道最有趣的是什么吗，我有一个绝妙的主意，因为我听了你关于茶壶那一集的精彩播客？我一直很好奇。你知道最有趣的是什么吗，我有一个绝妙的主意，因为我听了你关于茶壶那一集的精彩播客，我本来打算在房间里给它拍张照，结果完全忘了。我本来想在你那一集播出后就发出来的。
Oh my gosh, that would have blown my mind. Yeah. I'm sure there's a couple because in case anyone broke, you could probably get one, I'm sure. I know, but you have the teapot. That's huge. So there you go. So John, we are currently on the scene outside in the parking lot where Jim,
天哪，那会让我大吃一惊的。是的。我相信还有几个，以防有人弄坏了，你可能还能弄到一个，我肯定。我知道，但你有那个茶壶。那太重要了。所以就是这样。那么约翰，我们现在在停车场外面的场景，吉姆，
yeah, Roy just took off in his truck. Yeah, said, told me to keep an eye on you. Remember that? Yeah. Jenna's dressed as a bridesmaid Jenna looks like I am I remember talking to Jenna about this a couple times about like how Jenna's take on it was like or for Pam's take whatever she was like a little saucy of Jim to be like you got it like a little devious right from the beginning like this nice guy was like
是的，罗伊刚开着卡车走了。是的，告诉我盯着你。记得吗？是的。珍娜打扮成伴娘，珍娜看起来像我。我记得和珍娜聊过几次这个，关于珍娜对它的看法，或者帕姆的看法，不管是什么，她说吉姆有点轻浮，就像你得到了它，从一开始就有点狡猾，对吧？这个好人就像
oh you bet I'll take care of her oh I'll take care of her. No, I remember that that that moment in particular was insane for so many reasons because I remember how again, I keep talking about this like metaphysical thing, but I remember that like the cells of my body were really buzzing because I saw the crew running around and deciding where to hide the cameras. And Ken Quapus was our director and was phenomenal and making it feel like, it's no big deal, we're just doing a scene of a show
哦，你打赌我会照顾好她，哦，我会照顾好她。不，我记得那一刻特别疯狂，原因有很多，因为我记得，我一直在说这种形而上的东西，但我记得我身体的细胞真的在嗡嗡作响，因为我看到工作人员跑来跑去，决定把摄像机藏在哪里。肯·夸普斯是我们的导演，他非常出色，让一切感觉就像，没什么大不了的，我们只是在拍一个场景，
that'll never be seen. And then you're like, I think it's gonna be more than that. And he was like, who cares, just do it. Like he was trying to keep it so low. And I remember you and I were in a stair be more than that. He was like, who cares, just do it. Like he was trying to like keep it so low. And I remember you and I were in like a stairwell or something waiting. Yeah. And everybody was deciding, do you do the cameras?
永远不会被看到的场景。然后你说，我觉得它会不仅仅是那样。他说，谁在乎，做就是了。他试图让它保持低调。我记得你和我当时在楼梯间，不仅仅是那样。他说，谁在乎，做就是了。他试图让它保持低调。我记得你和我当时在楼梯间之类的等着。是的。每个人都在决定，要不要用摄像机？
Can they see the cameras? Can they not see the cameras? Meaning Jim and Pam, can they see the cameras, whatever? Are they aware of the documentary crew? And I remember, I think it was Ken, right? Who just said, I think I'm gonna make the decision that they don't. And I remember Matt, I think I remember this. Again, I'm elderly, but I feel like Ken placed the cameras
他们能看到摄像机吗？他们不能看到摄像机吗？意思是吉姆和帕姆，他们能看到摄像机吗，不管怎样？他们意识到纪录片摄制组的存在吗？我记得，我想是肯，对吧？他只是说，我想我会做一个决定，他们看不到。我记得马特，我想我记得这个。再说一次，我老了，但我感觉肯放置了摄像机
and didn't tell us exactly where they were gonna be. That sounds like Ken. Well, there was this big argument that went back to even when the script came out, which was should we film this scene with video or with audio only? Like this idea. And I think the reason we were in a stairwell
并没有告诉我们它们具体会在哪里。这听起来很像肯。好吧，当时有一个很大的争论，甚至追溯到剧本出来的时候，那就是我们应该用视频拍摄这个场景，还是只用音频？就像这个想法。我想我们在楼梯间的原因
for a very long time, John, was because they were deciding if we should have walked inside and gone onto the stairwell and we said the lines and right when we got to the end of the scene the camera would find us and we would be looking at each other in silence. Yes the idea was that Randall would be running to try to get it on film. Yes and that was kind of like Greg wanted that and like half the writers wanted that. Yeah. Imagine how good the show could have been if that was the case.
待了很长时间，约翰，是因为他们当时在决定我们是否应该走进去，进入楼梯间，然后我们说台词，就在场景结束时，摄像机会找到我们，我们会沉默地看着对方。是的，想法是兰德尔会跑着试图把它拍下来。是的，那是格雷格想要的，一半的编剧也想要。是的。想象一下，如果那样的话，这部剧会有多好。
I know. But instead. We could have succeeded. But then, and by the way, on Wikipedia, it claims that we shot that footage and it has never been seen, but that's not true. We never shot that. We only rehearsed it. I don't remember ever shooting a version.
我知道。但相反。我们本可以成功的。但后来，顺便说一句，在维基百科上，它声称我们拍摄了那段素材，但从未被看到，但那不是真的。我们从未拍摄过。我们只是排练了。我不记得拍过任何版本。
Do you? Yeah, I thought we rehearsed it. And then I thought, what I do remember maybe vaguely is that Ken was like, and if we do that version, we'll have the audio, so don't worry about it. Remember? Like I remember Ken, I think was saying to Greg, like, listen, Greg, the good news is if we do end up going that route,
你记得吗？是的，我以为我们排练过。然后我想，我模糊记得的是肯说，如果我们做那个版本，我们会有音频，所以别担心。记得吗？就像我记得肯，我想是在对格雷格说，听着，格雷格，好消息是如果我们最终走那条路，
we will already have the audio. Let's just shoot it out here first. And it was like a Jedi mind trick to get Greg to go with it. Right. But I do remember that they did, another reason we were in the stairwell was so that they were going to set the cameras outside. And when we came out, we wouldn't
我们已经有了音频。我们先在这里拍吧。这就像一个绝地武士的心灵诡计，让格雷格同意。没错。但我确实记得他们确实，我们在楼梯间的另一个原因是他们要把摄像机设置在外面。当我们出来时，我们不会
know where the cameras were. Right. And I remember feeling very alone in the parking lot. Well, again, because all the crew was kind of buzzy about it and like, hello. And like, all our great friends that I would be. I remember I was at the craft service table, not for this scene, but the next scene.
知道摄像机在哪里。没错。我记得在停车场感到非常孤独。好吧，再说一次，因为所有的工作人员都对此感到兴奋，就像，你好。就像，我们所有的好朋友。我记得我在餐车桌旁，不是为了这个场景，而是为了下一个场景。
And it's like, I remember going like, hey, Chris. Ooh, we were in fantasy football, one of my favorite people, Chris Workman. And I was like, hey, Chris. And he was like, hello, John. And then moved. And I was like, whoa, I don't think he's ever used the full word hello ever. That was the weirdest thing I've ever heard. Like everybody was so buzzed up about that. I don't remember this, Jenna. Do you have any semblance of an idea of how many takes of that we did? because I remember genuinely being extremely nervous,
就像，我记得我说，嘿，克里斯。噢，我们当时在玩梦幻足球，我最喜欢的人之一，克里斯·沃克曼。我说，嘿，克里斯。他说，你好，约翰。然后就走了。我当时想，哇，我不认为他曾经用过完整的“你好”这个词。这是我听过的最奇怪的事情。每个人都对那个场景感到非常兴奋。我不记得这个了，珍娜。你对我们拍了多少条有任何概念吗？因为我记得我当时真的非常紧张，
which I was like, this will be great for the scene, because I think it was probably, or at least I had probably interpreted it as the biggest scene I had done on the show, or something to that level of intensity, was like super terrifying to me, and I remember in my head being like, hey bro, remember when you thought you were an actor tonight ruins that whole mirage
我当时想，这对场景会很好，因为我想这可能是，或者至少我把它解读为我在剧里做过的最大的场景，或者达到那种强度的场景，对我来说超级可怕，我记得我在脑子里想，嘿兄弟，还记得你以为你是演员的时候吗，今晚毁了那个幻觉。
And oh hardly I was so I was so nervous to do that scene, but actually watching it again today It was really amazing because we were like kind of standing close to each other and it was like it was all very Awkward and perfect. It was so good. I wrote in my journal, oh my God, John Krasinski, and that tear, oh my God. I have it, I'm gonna screen grab it and send it to you, John. Please. Oh my God, you wrecked us, you wrecked me. You were so good.
噢，几乎没有，我当时太紧张了，无法完成那个场景，但今天再看一遍，真的很神奇，因为我们当时站得离彼此很近，一切都很尴尬且完美。太棒了。我在日记里写道，天哪，约翰·卡拉辛斯基，还有那滴眼泪，天哪。我有它，我要截屏发给你，约翰。拜托。天哪，你毁了我们，你毁了我。你太棒了。
Both you guys were so good. I think I also remember Ken being such a good director. I was like, you know, so in this scene, how you feeling? And, you know, how you feeling? And, and I was like, yeah, good. I said, you know, I'm going to be really honest with you, Ken. This is, this is a layup for me, bro, because I lived it. And he was like, what do you mean? And I was like, dude, in my high school yearbook, I have every single girl in the school being like, thank you so much, you are the shoulder to cry on.
你们俩都太棒了。我想我也记得肯是一个如此好的导演。我当时想，你知道，在这个场景里，你感觉如何？而且，你感觉如何？我说，是的，很好。我说，你知道，我会对你非常诚实，肯。这对我来说是个上篮，兄弟，因为我经历过。他说，你是什么意思？我说，伙计，在我高中的年鉴里，学校里的每一个女孩都说，太感谢你了，你是可以依靠的肩膀。
You were such a good friend when I was in love with Adam, like all this stuff, bro, I was like, no problem. So then when he was like, hey, do a scene about the love of your life, having another guy instead of you. And I was like, bro, it's called my default setting. Well, I, I remember shivering because I was freezing. It was really cold out and I was in that little dress and desert night. Oh, it was chilly. And I also, so here, here was something that I traded some messages with Ken Quapus about this scene.
当我爱上亚当的时候，你是一个如此好的朋友，所有这些，兄弟，我说，没问题。所以当他说，嘿，演一个关于你一生挚爱，却选择了另一个男人而不是你的场景。我说，兄弟，这叫我的默认设置。好吧，我记得我在发抖，因为我太冷了。外面很冷，我穿着那件小裙子，沙漠的夜晚。噢，很冷。而且我，所以这里，这里有一些我和肯·夸普斯关于这个场景交换的信息。
And he reminded me that we had actually filmed the kiss the night before. What? Yeah, we filmed the kiss the day before. And that this was the very final thing we shot for casino night. It took longer than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene. And we played around with the dialogue. So I have the script too. And
他提醒我，我们实际上在前一天晚上拍摄了吻戏。什么？是的，我们在前一天拍摄了吻戏。这是我们为赌场之夜拍摄的最后一件事情。它花费的时间比任何其他场景都长。我们在它上面花费的时间比任何其他场景都多。我们在它上面花费的时间比任何其他场景都多。我们玩弄了对话。所以我也有剧本。而且
what's in the script is a little different. And the thing is, is that that's my memory. I remember when I think back, the scene we were most nervous about was this scene. And people always ask about the kiss, but this was the scene we worked hardest on and it makes sense to me saying I'm in love with you is such a vulnerable thing and you do it so honestly John and I also remember that those lines Where I was saying like oh do you want me to take your money now or I could take it later or when do it? That was all banter that we came up with on the spot. And that you were going to then like shock me out of.
剧本里的内容有点不同。问题是，那是我的记忆。当我回想时，我们最紧张的场景就是这个。人们总是问关于吻戏的事，但这才是我们最努力工作的场景，这对我来说很有意义。说我爱你是一件如此脆弱的事情，你做得如此诚实，约翰。我也记得那些台词，我说，噢，你是想让我现在拿走你的钱，还是我可以晚点拿，或者什么时候拿？那都是我们当场想出来的玩笑。而且你当时要让我感到震惊。
And then I remember that stuff, that line where you said, when I'm like, I'm really sorry if you misinterpreted our friendship. And you're like, don't. When you said don't, that was an improv. And I like, my stomach, like my heart dropped into my stomach. I was like, oh my god, I'm so sorry. That's what I love is like you're doing this as Pam and as Jenny you're like, so sorry bro that was really rude. I was like everything. Like I was having to be Pam, but on the inside, I was like, I'm so sorry. Because you were, you know, and you, you cried in a couple of the takes, I remember.
然后我记得那些东西，你说的那句台词，当我像说，如果你误解了我们的友谊，我真的很抱歉。你说，别。当你说了别，那是即兴创作。我的胃，就像我的心掉进了胃里。我当时想，天哪，我太抱歉了。这就是我喜欢的，就像你作为帕姆和珍妮在做这件事，你就像，真抱歉兄弟，那真的很粗鲁。我当时想一切。就像我不得不成为帕姆，但在内心深处，我当时想，我太抱歉了。因为你，你知道，你在几条拍摄中哭了，我记得。
But the one that they used, I think was the first time,, because it was so it wrecked me, it wrecked me. And I was like, my job is just stand here and stare at him. And after they yelled cut, I feel like I was like, I'm sorry. Oh, my god, I'm terrible. There you are saying telling us now that you were there being like, Oh, my god, I'm so sorry. And watching it back today, I was like, Jesus, cold as ice. Like that was- She's so cold-hearted. That was cold-blooded.
但他们用的那一条，我想是第一次，因为它太，它毁了我，它毁了我。我当时想，我的工作就是站在这里盯着他。在他们喊停之后，我觉得我当时想，对不起。天哪，我太糟糕了。你现在告诉我们你当时在那里，就像，噢，天哪，我太抱歉了。今天回看它，我当时想，天哪，冷若冰霜。就像那是——她太冷酷了——那是冷血的。
That was so- It was cold, but I also think Pam was just like, and listen, John, I always defend Jim. Like throughout our podcast, when anything happens, I'm like, Pam is horrible. Poor Jim. She does. But in this moment, I really saw her as just totally completely
那是如此——那是冷的，但我同时也认为帕姆只是，听着，约翰，我总是为吉姆辩护。就像在我们的播客里，当发生任何事情时，我都会说，帕姆太糟糕了。可怜的吉姆。她确实。但在那一刻，我真的看到她只是完全彻底地
was deer in headlights. Like, everything was so real now. And once it's out there, it is out there, you know, and all of a sudden, she's gonna have to be accountable. Yes, I felt the same way watching it back. I was like, because I remember it differently. I remember like there were like three more moments in casino night of us flirting. And then when my man turns around and is like, I just want to tell you something. You're like, that's so fast. Even me was like, hey man, that is bad game. Stop.
像受惊的鹿。就像，一切现在都太真实了。一旦它说出来了，它就说出来了，你知道，突然之间，她将不得不负责。是的，回看时我也感觉一样。我当时想，因为我的记忆不同。我记得就像赌场之夜里还有三个我们调情的时刻。然后当我的男人转过身说，我只是想告诉你一些事。你就像，那太快了。连我都觉得，嘿伙计，那游戏玩得太烂了。停下。
You know what though, the scene that I loved was, and I realized it didn't come out of the blue is because of Jan. And when she goes, did you tell anybody? And I was like, right, he has to tell her now because he can never do it again. That was awesome. Such good writing. Who are those people?
你知道吗，我喜欢的场景是，我意识到它不是突如其来的，是因为简。当她说，你告诉任何人了吗？我当时想，对，他现在必须告诉她，因为他再也不能那样做了。那太棒了。写得真好。那些人是谁？
Also just like so kind. Like I feel like our, like Greg and Ken, like they were so gracious to let us have room to find those moments. You know, like they really like guys playing around. Right from the beginning. Like, we didn't need a lot of room after that. It was just so, but for those moments, you know, like they really like guys playing around right from the beginning. Like, yeah, we didn't need a lot of room after that. It's just so but for those moments, they were so respectful. So which again leads
也只是如此善良。就像我觉得我们的，就像格雷格和肯，他们非常慷慨地让我们有空间去寻找那些时刻。你知道，就像他们真的像玩耍的家伙。从一开始就是。就像，在那之后我们不需要太多空间。这只是，但对于那些时刻，你知道，他们真的像玩耍的家伙。从一开始就是。就像，是的，在那之后我们不需要太多空间。这只是，但对于那些时刻，他们如此尊重。所以这又引出了
to the second part, which is sorry, I'm jumping on your end. No, no, no, no, no, I'll move us along. But I wanted to say one more thing, which was when I was watching it back, I was like, what does Pam think Roy is secretly taping her or something? Like, she seemed like a spy who was like, I am very sorry, but I am loyal to Roy Anderson. I can't do this. You are a wonderful friend to me. But I obviously was impacting her because we're going to move into the bullpen and she goes up and calls her mom. To compliment your acting though, that, I mean, that has got to be my favorite thing
第二部分，也就是抱歉，我打断你了。不，不，不，我会带我们继续。但我还想说一件事，就是当我回看时，我当时想，帕姆认为罗伊在偷偷录音还是什么的？就像，她看起来像个间谍，说，我非常抱歉，但我忠于罗伊·安德森。我不能这样做。你是我很好的朋友。但我显然影响了她，因为我们要进入办公区，她走上去给她妈妈打电话。不过为了赞美你的演技，那，我的意思是，那一定是我最喜欢的事情
on any performance is when it's exactly what you imagine it would be, right? Because in the movies and TV, you're like, we've been programmed as kids to say that when someone says I love you, when you're sort of with someone else, you go, excuse me, how dare you in this whole dramatic thing. But instead your brain's just like, run the program, shut him down. Yeah. Like there's no emotion. Mayday, mayday, escape. Yes. Exactly.
在任何表演中，当它正是你想象的那样时，对吧？因为在电影和电视里，就像，我们从小就被编程说，当有人说我爱你，而你又和别人在一起时，你会说，对不起，你怎么敢，整个戏剧性的事情。但相反，你的大脑只是像，运行程序，关掉他。是的。就像没有情绪。五月天，五月天，逃跑。是的。完全正确。
Pull the cord. Pull the cord. Should we talk about the big old kiss? It's not even a big kiss. It's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial. It's also my first kiss., it's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial. It's also my first kiss. First kiss I ever had acting. That was my first acting kiss ever.
拉绳子。拉绳子。我们应该谈谈那个大吻吗？那甚至不是一个大吻。这是一个小吻，但它是完美的吻。它很充实。这也是我的初吻。，这是一个小吻，但它是完美的吻。它很充实。这也是我的初吻。我演戏以来的初吻。那是我第一次演戏接吻。
Mine was with Dwight. It was my second. Now that I say that, I'm wondering when else I would have had the opportunity, but like, no college play kissing, no nothing. That was nothing. Wow, that was your first on-screen kiss? My first fake kiss.
我的是和德怀特。那是我的第二次。现在我这么说，我在想我还有什么时候会有机会，但就像，没有大学戏剧接吻，什么都没有。那什么都不是。哇，那是你的银幕初吻？我的第一次假吻。
It was my second. I had done a movie called Born Champion. Oh. And I had a kiss scene in that. It was a sag, low-budget, I think maybe a non-union film. So I was one kiss more experienced than John. Which is a lot. I was so nervous.
那是我的第二次。我拍过一部叫《天生冠军》的电影。噢。我在里面有一场吻戏。那是演员工会，低预算，我想可能是一部非工会电影。所以我比约翰多了一次接吻经验。这很多。我当时太紧张了。
And here's something that Ken Quapus reminded me, John. He said, let me find it. It was so sweet. Ken said, I remember the day we did the kissing scene, you and John were off the charts nervous. And he said, he felt like it was his job to be really casual about the scene to kind of undercut how momentous it was. And I remember that he was being super casual about it, but he said, but what didn't help was that on the shooting schedule, the scene description read, Jim kisses Pam in all caps, italics, and three exclamation points. This is what we trade for people. You're like, okay,
这是肯·夸普斯提醒我的一件事，约翰。他说，让我找找。太甜了。肯说，我记得我们拍吻戏的那天，你和约翰紧张得不得了。他说，他觉得他的工作是让场景变得非常随意，以削弱它的重要性。我记得他当时对此非常随意，但他说了，但没用的是，在拍摄计划上，场景描述写着，吉姆吻了帕姆，全大写，斜体，还有三个感叹号。这就是我们为人们交换的东西。你就像，好吧，
This is what we trade for people you're like, okay And I think probably the crew was given the notice of like guys keep it cool, right? Let's not mess this up because that's when Chris Workman was like holding a you know a Plate of like peanut butter pretzels or something was like it Whoa, John and then like walked away and I was like Chris What the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer like walked away and I was like, Chris, what the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer for a while and I thought you were upset because I was on stage all the time because I was usually around crafty and I had heard that you were in your trailer and I was like, is everything okay? And I didn't know what was happening.
这就是我们为人们交换的东西。你就像，好吧。我想可能工作人员得到了通知，就像伙计们保持冷静，对吧？我们别搞砸了，因为那时克里斯·沃克曼正拿着一个，你知道，一盘花生酱椒盐卷饼之类的，就像，哇，约翰，然后走开了。我当时想，克里斯，那是什么鬼？但我还记得你在你的拖车里待了很久，我以为你很沮丧，因为我一直在舞台上，因为我通常在手工区附近，我听说你在拖车里，我当时想，一切都好吗？我不知道发生了什么。
And then I remember again, similarly, they told me that they were ready. And when I got on set, I was first on set at how I remember at least. I was first on set and was looking for Randall and Matt because I used to goof around with those guys. And weirdly, my default setting is like, make jokes when you're nervous. So I was looking for them and I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them because then I was looking for them and I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them, because then I was really nervous, because I was like, oh my God, if my bit machine isn't gonna work, then what do we do?
然后我记得同样地，他们告诉我他们准备好了。当我到达片场时，我至少记得我是第一个到片场的。我是第一个到片场的，在找兰德尔和马特，因为我过去常和那些家伙胡闹。奇怪的是，我的默认设置是，当你紧张时开玩笑。所以我当时在找他们，当我找不到他们时，我真的感到沮丧，因为那时我真的很紧张，因为我当时想，天哪，如果我的玩笑机器不工作，那我们该怎么办？
And then they were like, John, so you're gonna go to the front door? And I was like, front door, what's happening? And I got so, then I got so weirded out. And then someone came, I don't know if, was it Jazzmem was on yet? But I don't know, I think it was Jazz came up and was like,
然后他们说，约翰，所以你要去前门？我说，前门，发生了什么？我变得非常奇怪。然后有人来了，我不知道，是贾兹梅姆已经在场了吗？但我不知道，我想是贾兹走过来，就像，
and John, go. And I was like, I just remember like a person being like, and go. And it was like, I was in slow motion. I was like, do what? And I just went on and it was so weird. Well, I remember rehearsing. I'm gonna put that in quotes. I remember discussing the scene in the days prior. I had a bunch of meetings with Greg and you and Ken
约翰，走。我当时想，我只记得一个人说，走。就像，我处于慢动作中。我当时想，做什么？我只是走上去，这太奇怪了。好吧，我记得排练。我要把它放在引号里。我记得在几天前讨论过这个场景。我和格雷格、你还有肯开了很多会
where we all talked about it. Like, how big should the kiss be? I remember asking, how much does Pam kiss him back? We discussed that she would definitely allow herself to be kissed. And then, but did she really, like, kiss him back? How long should it go on? Like, just sort of general, chitty-chatness about how it would play out.
我们都谈论过它。就像，吻应该有多大？我记得我问过，帕姆回吻他多少？我们讨论过她肯定会允许自己被吻。然后，但她真的，就像，回吻他了吗？它应该持续多久？就像，关于它如何展开的某种一般的闲聊。
And then I remember on the day doing a very rough blocking of it, but alone. Like, when you were like, what is she doing in her trailer? They had brought me to set to rehearse by myself. This is where you're gonna stand at Jim's desk. There was a big discussion. Why am I not standing at reception?
然后我记得那天做了非常粗略的走位，但独自一人。就像，当你问她在拖车里做什么时？他们带我到片场独自排练。这就是你要站在吉姆办公桌的地方。有一个很大的讨论。为什么我不站在接待处？
It was because it would be too hard for you to get to me. They wanted to put the camera in the kitchen so that we couldn't see it. They would shoot it through the blinds. It would be super secret spy shot. And that was the best position. We worked out exactly how I would stand with the phone. And then they said, now we want you to go back to your
这是因为你很难靠近我。他们想把摄像机放在厨房里，这样我们就看不见它了。他们会透过百叶窗拍摄。那将是一次超级秘密的间谍拍摄。而且那是最好的位置。我们精确地计算了我该如何拿着电话站立。然后他们说，现在我们要你回到你的
trailer and not leave until you're called. Oh, wow. And don't speak to john and be alone. And so it was super secret. Yes, they they talk about this in the DVD commentary guys. I wasn't there. But I listened to the DVD commentary commentary and they wanted to keep you guys apart That's yeah, that's something that they do. I think Like I'm reminiscing about it now with you and I remember one time talking to Brian about it years later And I was like, oh man, like I remember that was the the last thing we shot that day He goes no it was not and I was like, what are you talking about and he goes we were all in our trailers like oh god let's go we were in our trailer for like three hours like I took a nap
拖车里，在被叫到之前不要离开。哦，哇。而且不要和约翰说话，要一个人待着。所以这真是超级秘密。是的，他们在DVD评论里谈到了这一点，伙计们。我当时不在场。但我听了DVD评论，他们想让你们分开。是的，那是他们会做的事情。我想，我现在和你一起回忆这件事，我记得多年后有一次和布莱恩谈起这件事，我说，哦天哪，我记得那是我们那天拍的最后一个镜头。他说不，不是。我说，你在说什么？他说我们都待在拖车里，哦天哪，我们走吧，我们在拖车里待了大约三个小时，我睡了一觉
someone was like what is happening I know my memory is that that was the last thing we did that day me too and we could take as much time as we wanted not all of us were in our trailers being like, you gotta be kidding me with these two. Oh no! Oh no! I thought it was the end of the day and we were all the time in the world. That's what I said to Ryan! Oh my goodness. He's right. But I don't know, you guys, it was such an important scene. They had to find it. And in the commentary, they talk about how they wanted the first time that john is Jim saw Pam was in that moment on action. Yeah, that they never rehearsed it on the stage together. And
有人说发生了什么事？我知道我的记忆是那天我们做的最后一件事。我也是，我们可以随心所欲地花时间，并不是我们所有人都待在拖车里想，你们这两个人真是开玩笑吧。哦不！哦不！我以为那是那天结束的时候，我们有的是时间。这就是我对瑞安说的！哦天哪。他是对的。但我不知道，伙计们，那是一个如此重要的场景。他们必须找到它。在评论中，他们谈到了他们希望约翰，也就是吉姆，第一次见到帕姆是在那一刻，在行动中。是的，他们从未在舞台上一起排练过。而且
then I remember they brought me to set and all the lights were dim. There was no one around. It was super creepy. Yeah, that's right. So there was no one around. It was super eerie. Yeah, that was creepy. Yeah, that was, and that's what I mean. So there was no crew. And that's when they were like. Yeah. Nothing. And they were like. John, please move to the entrance. I was like, who is that?
然后我记得他们把我带到片场，所有的灯光都调暗了。周围没有人。这超级令人毛骨悚然。是的，没错。所以周围没有人。这非常诡异。是的，那很令人毛骨悚然。是的，那是，这就是我的意思。所以没有工作人员。那就是他们说的时候。是的。什么都没有。他们说。约翰，请移步到入口处。我说，那是谁？
Is that the devil? Who just saw him? I love that in your mind, John, it's like, slow down. You're like, you know. Yeah, but it's super like scary, like weird. And then Ken, I think, and Greg, were hiding maybe in the conference room in the very back corner with a little thing, like a little, I don't know what is that, like a handheld
那是魔鬼吗？谁刚看到他？我喜欢你在脑海里的想法，约翰，就像，慢下来。你就像，你知道的。是的，但这超级吓人，很奇怪。然后肯，我想，还有格雷格，可能躲在会议室最里面的角落里，拿着一个小东西，就像一个小，我不知道那是什么，就像一个手持的
video monitor that they could see what the camera is shooting. We only used one camera. It was only the camera in the kitchen. So it was a one shot. There was no way to cut. We had to get it all a one shot. There was no way to cut. We had to get it all in one shot. Mm-hmm. And I remember I'm doing the bit with my mom on the phone, and then you walked in, and we shot the kiss,
视频监视器，他们可以看到摄像机在拍什么。我们只用了一台摄像机。只有厨房里的那台摄像机。所以这是一个长镜头。没有办法剪辑。我们必须一次性拍完。没有办法剪辑。我们必须一次性拍完。嗯哼。我记得我正在电话里和我妈妈演戏，然后你走了进来，我们拍了吻戏，
and then we're staring at each other, and Ken said, cut. And do you remember Greg? Do you remember Greg running out of the conference room like clapping his hands? He was like, he was giddy. He was like, Yeah, he was like, so good. It was so good. How many takes of that did we do? Three. Wow.
然后我们盯着对方看，肯喊了停。你还记得格雷格吗？你还记得格雷格从会议室跑出来拍手吗？他当时很兴奋。他就像，是的，他就像，太好了。太好了。我们拍了多少次？三次。哇。
I know the commentary said that he put on sorry, I wrote it down. Greg said he picked the last take. The last take was his favorite. Oh, interesting! Ken Kwapis and Kent Zbornak both confirmed we only did three takes of this scene, and Ken said that Greg wanted to keep doing it over and over and over again and Ken had to convince him that we had it. Wow. But Greg was like, it's just so good. It's just so good.
我知道评论里说他选了，抱歉，我记下来了。格雷格说他选了最后一次拍摄。最后一次拍摄是他最喜欢的。哦，有趣！肯·夸皮斯和肯特·兹博纳克都证实我们这个场景只拍了三次，肯说格雷格想一遍又一遍地拍，肯不得不说服他我们已经拍好了。哇。但格雷格就像，这太好了。这太好了。
And he wanted to keep doing it. And and Ken was like, no, we're going to wear them out. We're going to wear them out. That's obviously where the voice was coming from. I imagine Greg just being like, dance for me. You're like, what? You can't say that. Awkward. Awkward.
他想继续拍。肯就像，不，我们会把他们累坏的。我们会把他们累坏的。那显然是声音传来的地方。我想象格雷格就像，为我跳舞。你就像，什么？你不能那样说。尴尬。尴尬。
That's so weird. There's one other thing in the DVD commentary, you guys, I thought was really cool is that Randall Einhorn said that he really wanted it to end so that you couldn't see Pam's face. So you never knew what her reaction was after that. That's right. So that was really thought out that Jenna, you never looked around like you were facing this one way and Cameron never saw your face after the kiss.
这太奇怪了。DVD评论里还有一件事，伙计们，我觉得真的很酷，那就是兰德尔·艾因霍恩说他真的很想让它结束，这样你就看不到帕姆的脸了。所以你永远不知道她在那之后的反应是什么。没错。所以这真的是经过深思熟虑的，珍娜，你从来没有环顾四周，就像你面对着这个方向，摄像机在吻戏后从来没有拍到你的脸。
Yeah, that was part of what he argued for only using one camera. That there was some discussion that another camera would come around by the front door and capture Pam's side of everything and sneak in. But he was like, no, I think we only managed to get one shot of this. So you don't know.
是的，这就是他主张只使用一台摄像机的原因之一。有人讨论过另一台摄像机会绕到前门，捕捉帕姆那一侧的一切并偷偷溜进去。但他就像，不，我想我们只拍到了一个镜头。所以你不知道。
It was amazing. Yeah, crazy. It was beautiful, you guys. You guys crushed it. Guys, this was the most fun ever to talk about this. I mean. It was fun to reminisce. You guys, guys, congratulations on this podcast.
这太棒了。是的，疯狂。这很美，伙计们。你们表现得太棒了。伙计们，谈论这个真是太有趣了。我是说。回忆起来很有趣。伙计们，伙计们，祝贺你们的播客。
It is so much fun. And I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean, you guys guys congratulations on this podcast. It is so much fun and I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean you guys do such a good job. You're so nice. Thank you. Thanks so much. I don't know if there's two people from our show who like talking as much as us. Do you remember? Who talk constantly. Do you remember? Right now Brian's at home going like we know that's true. You're like Brian geez settle down. Do you remember how Rain would make fun of us? He would say, there they go. Baka-dika-baka-dika-baka.
这太有趣了。我不认为还有两个人能做到这一点。我是说，你们伙计们，祝贺你们的播客。这太有趣了，我不认为还有两个人能做到这一点。我是说你们做得太好了。你们太好了。谢谢。非常感谢。我不知道我们节目里还有没有像我们一样喜欢说话的两个人。你记得吗？谁一直在说话。你记得吗？现在布莱恩在家里想，我们知道那是真的。你就像布莱恩，天哪，冷静点。你记得雷恩是怎么取笑我们的吗？他会说，他们又来了。巴卡-迪卡-巴卡-迪卡-巴卡。
Like, we'd be like. Yeah, Rain would be like, what more could you possibly have to say to one another? I know. God. Our crudgeon. Our curmudgeon. Our curmudgeon.
就像，我们会说。是的，雷恩会说，你们还能有什么可说的？我知道。天哪。我们的老顽固。我们的老顽固。我们的老顽固。
I love you both so much. Thank you so much for doing. Thanks for having me. We love you, John. Thanks for coming on. That was so great. We hope you enjoyed it as much as we did. Yeah.
我非常爱你们俩。非常感谢你们所做的一切。谢谢你们邀请我。我们爱你，约翰。谢谢你来参加。那太棒了。我们希望你们像我们一样喜欢它。是的。
Thank you, John. John Krasinski, you're the best. He is the best. He is the best. But Jenna, before we say goodbye, there are one or two moments that fans wrote in about. We have to talk about the phone call between Pam and her mom. We have to talk about this moment. Yes we got so much mail about this. Erin Louise, Matt Loveless, Mrs. Prince, Brianna and EJ.
谢谢你，约翰。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，你是最棒的。他是最棒的。他是最棒的。但是珍娜，在我们说再见之前，粉丝们写信提到了有一两个时刻。我们必须谈谈帕姆和她妈妈之间的电话。我们必须谈谈这一刻。是的，我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。艾琳·路易丝、马特·洛夫莱斯、普林斯夫人、布里安娜和EJ。
They all wanted to know if there was another side to this phone call. Mm-hmm. Well I'll tell you this guys, there was no one on the other line. Jenna, I was just pretending. And the Emmy goes to Jenna Fisher. My God, that's some good phone talk, lady. Yeah, no one was there. No one was there. I invented in my head what the dialogue was.
他们都想知道这个电话是否有另一面。嗯哼。好吧，我告诉你们，伙计们，电话那头没有人。珍娜，我只是在假装。艾美奖颁给珍娜·费舍尔。天哪，那真是很棒的电话交谈，女士。是的，没有人。没有人。我在脑子里编造了对话内容。
Yeah. And I had written it down in my script for what I thought my mom was saying to me so that I would have good reactions and I was going through it in my head as I was doing the scene. That's me applauding my BFF. Oh my gosh. Thank you. Yeah. So there was one line in particular that everyone honed in on, which is when Pam says, yeah, I think I am. Yeah. What was she responding to? I mean, I know what I thought.
是的。我在剧本里写下了我认为我妈妈在对我说什么，这样我就能有好的反应，我在演戏的时候在脑子里过了一遍。那是我在为我的闺蜜鼓掌。哦天哪。谢谢。是的。所以有一个特别的台词每个人都注意到了，那就是帕姆说，是的，我想我是。是的。她在回应什么？我是说，我知道我在想什么。
I think I know what all the fans think. What do you think? I think I am in love with him. That is what I had written in my script, that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him. That is what I had written in my script that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him? Yeah. And that I answered, yeah, mom, I think I am. Oof. Yeah. Oh, Pam. And then we got a fan question. A lot of people actually asked this question. Alyssa Dunn, Carrie Harvey and
我想我知道所有粉丝在想什么。你觉得呢？我想我爱上他了。这就是我在剧本里写的，我妈妈问我，亲爱的，你爱上他了吗？这就是我在剧本里写的，我妈妈问我，亲爱的，你爱上他了吗？是的。我回答说，是的，妈妈，我想我是。哎呀。是的。哦，帕姆。然后我们收到了一个粉丝问题。实际上很多人问了这个问题。艾丽莎·邓恩、嘉莉·哈维和
more wanted to know if we knew what the next season would bring to the Jim Pam storyline when we shot those scenes in the parking lot and in the in the office. Right. No we did not. We were not told what would happen to them. It was a cliffhanger to the cast as well. I have to think that Greg probably had a few ideas and didn't want to tell us anything until it would become more concrete for him what the plan was, you know? Mm-hmm.
更多人想知道，当我们拍摄停车场和办公室里的那些场景时，我们是否知道下一季会给吉姆和帕姆的故事线带来什么。不，我们不知道。没有人告诉我们会发生什么。这对演员来说也是一个悬念。我不得不认为格雷格可能有一些想法，并且不想告诉我们任何事情，直到对他来说计划变得更具体，你知道吗？嗯哼。
I would think. I think he had an idea that they were gonna have Jim go to Stanford. Well, yeah. But a few weeks before we went back into production for the season three, I did get called in to do a bunch of chemistry read auditions with possible Karens. And that was my first insight into what was going to happen in season three.
我想是的。我想他有一个想法，他们会让吉姆去斯坦福。嗯，是的。但在我们回到第三季制作的前几周，我确实被叫去和可能的凯伦们一起做了一堆化学反应试镜。那是我第一次洞察到第三季会发生什么。
Oh, that's juicy. That would have been that's like good intel back then because we were all clueless. We didn't know what was gonna happen. I think another cliffhanger is, obviously the Dwight Angelo was happening with them, but then also what is gonna happen with Jan and Michael? Because you see that Jan actually did pack an overnight bag in her car.
哦，那很有趣。那在当时可是很好的情报，因为我们都一无所知。我们不知道会发生什么。我想另一个悬念是，显然德怀特和安吉拉在他们之间发生了一些事情，但还有简和迈克尔会发生什么？因为你看到简确实在她的车里打包了一个过夜包。
Yes, yes. As she's leaving, the camera finds this overnight bag. She was 100% planning to hook up with Michael. Yeah, and just sleep over at his place Which is a big deal. Well, I did hear in the DVD commentary that it was this episode that Melora Hardin and David Denman Became series regulars. So we knew that they were gonna be coming back, but we didn't know how. Wow, there we go. There we go guys, that was a big, big episode. We hope you enjoyed it.
是的，是的。当她离开时，摄像机发现了这个过夜包。她百分之百计划和迈克尔在一起。是的，还要在他家过夜。这可是件大事。好吧，我确实在DVD评论里听说，正是这一集，梅洛拉·哈丁和大卫·丹曼成为了系列常驻演员。所以我们知道他们会回来，但我们不知道以什么方式。哇，就是这样。就是这样，伙计们，那是非常非常重要的一集。我们希望你们喜欢它。
We certainly enjoyed getting to watch it again and talk to John and all the cast members we texted and Kintapedia. Thank you so much for giving us such great behind the scenes moments. Yes, and guys, after we did that interview with John, Angela and I were a part of his show, Some Good News. It was so much fun.
我们当然很享受再次观看它，并与约翰以及我们发短信的所有演员成员交谈。非常感谢你们给我们带来如此精彩的幕后时刻。是的，伙计们，在我们采访约翰之后，安吉拉和我参加了他的节目《一些好消息》。那太有趣了。
First of all, my family and I are such huge fans of Some Good News. We've watched every episode, and what John is doing, the goodness he's putting out there is so wonderful. And Jenna, wasn't it a blast? It was so much fun. If you guys haven't seen it, you have to check it out. There's this couple, their names are John and Susan Lush.
首先，我和我的家人是《一些好消息》的超级粉丝。我们看了每一集，约翰所做的事情，他传播的善意是如此美妙。珍娜，那不是很棒吗？那太有趣了。如果你们还没看过，一定要去看看。有一对夫妇，他们的名字是约翰和苏珊·拉什。
They're from Maryland. And when they got engaged, they reenacted Jim and Pam's engagement at the gas station. But then because of the pandemic, their May wedding was canceled. So John surprised them. We might have recreated the dance down the aisle from Jim and Pam's wedding.
他们来自马里兰州。当他们订婚时，他们重演了吉姆和帕姆在加油站的订婚。但后来因为疫情，他们五月的婚礼被取消了。所以约翰给了他们一个惊喜。我们可能重现了吉姆和帕姆婚礼上走过过道的舞蹈。
And it was just so much fun and such a wonderful thing to be a part of. Yeah, the thing that John is doing with that, it's just, it's great. He's bringing some light and love to the world. And John, we love you. We love you. And you guys, we will see you next week
那真是太有趣了，能参与其中真是太美妙了。是的，约翰用那个做的事情，真是太棒了。他给世界带来了一些光明和爱。约翰，我们爱你。我们爱你。伙计们，我们下周见
with Can You Believe It? The first episode of season three, Gay Witch Hunt. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins,
《你能相信吗？》第三季的第一集，《同性恋猎巫》。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，
and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。